nach der videoseite letzte woche stolz
die ampel verweigerte die von der
opposition verlangte aussprache heute
nun wird es wohl geben es ist die erste
generaldebatte seit dem
regierungswechsel und es dürfte eine
spannende debatte werden noch hat sie
nicht begonnen vor ort im bundestag wird
meine kollegin andrea maurer die reden
verfolgen schönen guten morgen andrea
was ist denn das besondere an der
heutigen debatte was ist denn da zu
erwarten
jaja guten morgen patricia also mit
großer spannung wird hier heute der
auftritt des oppositionsführers erwartet
es ist ja traditionell so dass die
generaldebatte eröffnet wird vom
generator positions- führer und der
aktuelle oppositionsführer heißt
friedrich merz er wird vor dem kanzler
sprechen und er ist bekannt für wuchtige
worte und auch eine wuchtige rhetorik
allerdings ist sind er und die union
auch in einem dilemma konstruktive
opposition das wollten sie bislang seien
aber nun suchen sie tatsächlich in den
letzten tagen auch noch einmal mehr nach
profil als opposition konstruktiv
kritisch nennen sie sich nun und es ist
die frage wie viel kritik friedrich merz
hier heute vorbringen wird wie er sich
positionieren wird welchen ton er auch
setzen wird das ist auf jeden fall etwas
was wir hier gleich mit großer spannung
beobachten was hier gleich hinter mir
beginnt ja einen kleinen vorgeschmack
hat man ja gestern schon in der debatte
bekommen gestern gab es ja schon klare
ansagen der union dass sie den von
scholz angekündigten zusätzlichen 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr nur unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen zustimmen
werden
ja es ist tatsächlich so dass die union
als scholz eben in seiner
regierungserklärung dieses
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
verkündet hat da sind die
unionsabgeordneten ja aufgestanden haben
gejubelt sie sind auch grundsätzlich für
dieses sondervermögen sie werden auch
gebraucht für eine zweidrittelmehrheit
um dieses sondervermögen im grundgesetz
zu verankern aber tatsächlich stellen
sie nun forderungen also sie wollen das
eins zu eins dieses geld der bundeswehr
zur verfügung gestellt wird und dass
klar wird wie wird eigentlich dieser
kredit der dafür aufgenommen wird
gekickt andrea ganz herzlichen dank ich
höre es geht los wir schauen jetzt mal
rein ins plenum
sehr geehrten damen und herren am 27
februar also vor mehr als drei wochen
haben sie herr bundeskanzler von dieser
stelle aus eine regierungserklärung
abgegeben und von einer zeitenwende
gesprochen wir teilen diese einschätzung
unverändert
zumal putin seinen krieg in der ukraine
immer
brutaler gegen die zivilbevölkerung
führt und wir bis heute kein mittel
gefunden haben dieses verbrechen zu
beenden es ist in der tat eine
zeitenwende
aber erlauben sie mir meine damen und
herren einen eindruck wiederzugeben den
meine fraktion und auch ich persönlich
in der gestrigen debatte gewonnen haben
in ihrer koalition auch in der
einbringung rede des
bundesfinanzministers ist von einer
zeitenwende nicht wirklich viel zu
bemerken gewesen
sie gehen von grundannahmen aus von dem
wir schon heute wissen dass sie einfach
nicht stimmt das wachstum unserer
volkswirtschaft wird in diesem jahr 2022
nicht 3,6 prozent betragen sondern
deutlich weniger
die inflationsrate wird nicht wieder
sinken sondern sie wird er weiter
steigen die lieferketten sind
unterbrochen und wir müssen befürchten
dass weitere lieferketten unterbrochen
werden die steuereinnahmen werden
vermutlich deutlich niedriger ausfallen
als erwartet und vor allem die ausgaben
werden durch den ukrainer krieg und alle
seine folgen deutlich steigen das wissen
wir alle dass wissen auch sie sprechen
beschönigend von einem ergänzungs
haushalt den sie wahrscheinlich schon im
nächsten monat vorliegen müssen und zwar
in einer größenordnung von bis zu 50
milliarden euro und trotzdem legen sie
in dieser woche einen bundeshaushalt vor
so als ob nichts gewesen wäre meine
damen und herren im grunde genommen wenn
es richtig ist was sie sagen herr
bundeskanzler mit der zeitenwende dann
müssen sie große teile ihres
koalitionsvertrages eigentlich heute
neun verhandeln
die einzige die einzige wirklich
ernsthaft der abweichung von allem dem
was im letzten jahr auch schon richtig
war ist der plan ein sondervermögen über
100 milliarden euro zu errichten für die
bundeswehr
wenn ich richtig zugehört habe und ich
bin gestern vormittag den ganzen tag
hier gewesen und habe wirklich versucht
aufmerksam zuzuhören wenn ich richtig
zugehört habe dann hat gestern keiner
der redner der koalition hier im
parlament von den notwendigen 2 prozent
gesprochen keiner das wort hat keine
rolle
deshalb möchte ich gerne noch mal an die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
hier vom 27 februar erinnern sie haben
diese sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
euro vorgeschlagen und haben dann
anschließend gesagt wörtlich wir werden
von nun an jahr für jahr mehr als zwei
prozent mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes in unsere
verteidigung investieren der eindruck
ist entstanden 100 milliarden plus 2
prozent jedes jahr den eindruck haben
sie entstehen lassen durch diese reden
kannst verstehen
sie haben dann im nächsten satz den
vorschlag unterbreitet dieses
sondervermögen also in wahrheit 100
milliarden euro neue schulden an der
schuldengrenze des grundgesetzes vorbei
eben in die verfassung in das
grundgesetz aufzunehmen und damit zeigt
sich jetzt in der systematik wie sie
haushaltsplanung machen ein gewisses
bild
das bild ist wie folgt sie schöpfen den
kernhaushalt so nennen sie ja
mittlerweile den bundeshaushalt der
eigentlich bundeshaushalt sein soll der
heißt jetzt bei ihnen kernhaushalt sie
schöpfen diesen kernhaushalt bis zur
obergrenze der möglichen schulden aus
sie verlängern die feststellung einer
notlage aus der korona pandemie mit der
schulden mit dem aussetzen der
schuldenbremse und beanspruchen weiter
auch in diesem jahr zusätzliche 100
milliarden euro schulden 60 milliarden
davon transferieren sie zweckentfremdet
in einem fonds den sie jetzt klima und
transformation vom nennen also ein
klassischer nebenhaushalt sie kündigen
jetzt schon an diese notlage noch in
diesem jahr erneut zu beantragen sie
können sie nicht feststellen sie können
sie nur beantragen weil wir müssen sie
hier beschließen zu beantragen weil es
unvorhergesehene ausgaben aus dem krieg
in der ukraine gibt und weil das alles
nicht reicht soll die schuldenbremse des
grundgesetzes im grundgesetz selbst mit
noch einmal 100 milliarden euro schulden
für die bundeswehr einmalig ganz außer
kraft gesetzt werden das ist die
systematik nur um das einmal klar zu
machen was sie unter so haben die sehr
bundesfinanzminister gestern ihr
mehrfach gesagt unter einer soliden und
stetigen haushaltsplanung und
haushaltsführung verstehen
ammonium
kein zweifel daran lassen dass auch wir
es für dringend notwendig erachten die
bundeswehr mit mehr mitteln auszustatten
sie neu auszurüsten
wissen sie dass nun ausgerechnet von der
fdp an dieser stelle immer wieder
zwischenrufe kommen ist insofern ist
insofern erstaunlich als in den letzten
vier wahlperioden in keiner einzigen
wahlperiode der etat des bundesministers
der verteidigung so gering angestiegen
ist wie in der zeit wo sie an der
regierung beteiligt gewesen in die
seinerzeit in keiner zeit ist der
verteidigungshaushalt so schlecht
behandelt worden in der zeit wo sie die
fdp in der regierung war nur dass man zu
den zwischenrufen die wir hier ständig
also meine damen und herren wir haben
das wir haben das hier ja also
sie machen es sie machen das mit diesem
permanenten zwischenrufen sie machen das
mit diesen permanenten zwischenrufen
nicht nur sich selber schwerer als es
notwendig ist sie machen es auch uns
frau strack-zimmermann sie als
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
sind zu einer gewissen zurückhaltung
verpflichtet und zu einer probe einer
gewinnt sie wenn sie hier das sprachrohr
wenn sie hier das sprachrohr der
zwischenrufe aus ihrer fraktionen werden
dann diskreditieren sie sich selbst als
vorsitzender dieses ausschusses die
eigentlich die wichtigste aufgabe hat
dieses problem gemeinsam mit uns zu
lösen und es ist unnötig schwer zu
machen nicht unnötig schwer zu machen
wir stehen heute
wir stehen heute im grunde genommen da
[Applaus]
wo wir vor 40 jahren schon einmal
standen als wir über die nachrüstung in
der nato und in der bundeswehr sprechen
mussten und wo wir damals das glück
hatten einen bundeskanzler helmut
schmidt zu haben der das gegen seine
eigene partei durchgesetzt hat hätte er
es nicht wäre die geschichte nach 1982
anders verlaufen als sie verlaufen ist
meine damen und herren und genau an
dieser stelle stehen wir heute wieder
genau an dieser stelle stehen wir heute
wieder eine nicht nur eine massive
bedrohung sondern eine tatsächlich
eingetretene kriegerische
auseinandersetzung in europa ausgehend
von russland gegen dient wir gegen die
wir jetzt etwas entgegenzusetzen haben
und deswegen die durch hiervon meine
fraktion feststellen wir wollen jetzt
wirklich der bundeswehr helfen und wir
sehen
[Applaus]
ich weiß gar nicht was was ist an diesem
satz falsch was was bringt sie zu
solchen reaktionen
entschuldigung wir wollen der bundeswehr
jetzt wirklich helfen und deswegen noch
mal meine damen und herren noch mal
meine damen und herren wir stehen dazu
wir wollen dies und der bundeskanzler
sie werden verstehen dass wir wenn sie
den weg einer grundgesetzänderung hier
gehen wollen dies nur unter klar
vereinbarten geregelten vereinbarungen
überhaupt erwägen mitzugehen und ich
will ihnen sechs punkte sagen wie wir
uns das vorstellen können erstens
na ja meine damen und herren sie wollen
von uns die zustimmung zu einer
grundgesetzänderung
also ich darf man hier eine feststellung
treffen weil weil sie hier so ständig
dazwischen rufen sie bemühen sich
vernünftigerweise um gespräche mit uns
wir sollen viele dinge mit ihnen
zusammen machen deswegen zwei
feststellungen erster feststellungen sie
werden in zukunft für jedes gesetz was
sie im deutschen bundestag verabschieden
eine eigenständige mehrheit brauchen die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist nicht die
ersatzbank von der sie sich beliebiger
weise mal ersatzspieler aufstelle und
wenn sie ihre eigene mehrheit das gilt
für alle vor einschließlich
einschließlich der insel damit das klar
zweitens wenn wir überhaupt zu einer
grundgesetzänderung kommen wenn wir
überhaupt zu einer grundgesetzänderung
kommen dann füllen wir das in der weise
auf das dann eine zweidrittelmehrheit
zustande kommt aber nicht so dass dann
von einige von ihnen hier sagen da
machen wir nicht mit die union wird es
ja schon richten nein wir richten es
nicht sie werden mit jedem einzelnen
abgeordneten ihr ja sagen müssen zu dem
was dann mit der grundgesetzänderung
verbunden sein wird getreten einzeln
schon das geht nur unter folgenden
bedingungen
das geht nur unter folgenden bedingungen
erstens wir wollen und wir werden sie
herr bundeskanzler festhalten an den
zugesagten 2 prozent nicht 100
milliarden sondern zwei prozent
zweitens
die ausgaben müssen so wie sie es hier
gesagt haben investitionen in die
bundeswehr sein und für nichts anderes
nur für die bundeswehr sie können von
mir aus die fünf von mir aus
feministischer außenpolitik machen
feministische entwicklungshilfepolitik
das können sie alles machen aber nicht
mit diesem etat für die bundeswehr
wir schlagen ihnen vor
wir schlagen ihnen vor dass wir
begleitend ein gesetz über die
fähigkeiten und die finanzierung der
bundeswehr verabschieden damit dies auch
in einem einfach gesetzlichen rahmen
festgehalten wird drittens die zwei
prozent des bip müssen dauerhaft
erreicht werden und nicht nur einmalig
rein rechnerisch sind sie mit den 100
milliarden nach fünf jahren bereits
erschöpft wir wollen dass über diese
fünf jahre hinaus nicht irgendwo sondern
im kernhaushalt der bundesrepublik
deutschland die kernaufgabe verteidigung
mit mehr als zwei prozent des bip der
bundesrepublik deutschland finanziert
wird das ist die voraussetzung dass wir
da überhaupt zu einer gemeinsamen lösung
konnte
viertens wir wollen vor der
verabschiedung wir wollen vor der
verabschiedung wissen welche
anschaffungen für die bundeswehr aus den
100 milliarden euro denn finanziert
werden sollen dem gesetzentwurf den sie
vorgelegt haben im kabinett
verabschiedet haben über die errichtung
eines sondervermögens fehlt die anlage
die anlage heißt wirtschaftsplan der
wirtschaftsplan ist nicht vorhanden den
haben sie bereits den haben sie noch
nicht verabschiedet das ist in ordnung
so das kann man wahrscheinlich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt auch nicht aber wir
werden nicht 100 milliarden euro hier
blankoscheck erteilen und sie machen
anschließend damit was sie wollen das
ist nicht die arbeitszeit wir schlagen
ihnen vor
wir schlagen ihnen vor dass es dazu ein
geeignetes begleit gremium gibt dass
darüber wacht dass dies auch tatsächlich
stattfindet und dass diese investitionen
in die bundeswehr in den nächsten jahren
auch tatsächlich erfolgen wir wollen in
diesem begleit gremium dauerhaft mit
darüber entscheiden wie die
investitionen der bundeswehr umgesetzt
werden
55 kings ich weiß dass sie so denken der
bundeskanzler deswegen will ich es gerne
aufgreifen wir müssen gemeinsam
versuchen das beschaffungswesen zu
ändern es hat doch keinen sinn ist so zu
lassen wie es heute ist dass da eine
behörde in koblenz sitzt und arbeitet
eine riese ein riesenstau ein riesen
rückstau in den genehmigungen
erfolgt und diese 100 milliarden nicht
wirklich ausgegeben werden können das
beschaffungswesen muss anders
organisiert werden als es heute
organisiert ist und schließlich sechs
sind
wenn ihr meine damen und herren wenn wir
schon eine ausnahme von der
schuldenbremse im grundgesetz machen und
diese mit einer grundgesetzänderung
beschließen das ist ja der mechanismus
dann muss indem errichtungs gesetz über
das sondervermögen das ja nur aus
schulden besteht auch ein tilgungsplan
hinterlegt werden
ich will auf diesen sachverhalt
hinweisen und zwar aus einem ganz
einfachen grund es kann doch wohl nicht
sein dass bei einer verfassungsgemäßen
überschreitung der schuldenobergrenze
von verfassungs wegen einen tilgungsplan
vorgelegt werden muss und dann mit einer
zusätzlichen ausnahme von dieser
schuldenobergrenze mit der noch mehr
schulden gemacht werden müssen einen
tilgungsplan nicht erstellt wird das ist
ihre vorstellung aber nicht unsere herr
bundeskanzler
lassen sie mich noch einmal zur
ausgangslage zurück kommen zu dem was
sie mit zeitenwende beschrieben haben
wir wir brauchen einige informationen
wir hätten gerne von ihnen der
bundeskanzler gleich in ihrem
redebeitrag hier einige fragen
beantwortet die erste frage ist welche
waffen hat die bundesrepublik
deutschland denn nun eigentlich wirklich
geliefert diese frage müssen wir hier
leider stellen weil diese frage müssen
wir leider stellen weil das was da
geliefert worden sein soll wird unter
geheimhaltungs vorbehalt gestellt im
verteidigungsausschuss wird darüber
unter geheim informiert so weit ich
informiert bin auch nicht sauber
informiert es gibt spekulationen in der
öffentlichkeit dass das was sie zugesagt
haben gar nicht geliefert worden ist und
das was bestellt werden könnte entweder
im kanzleramt oder im
wirtschaftsministerium oder im
außenministerium blockiert wird und
nicht genehmigt wird herr bundeskanzler
es wäre gut wenn sie hier klarheit
schaffen und gleich in ihrem beitrag
sagen was die bundesrepublik deutschland
liefert und was sie gegebenenfalls auch
was sie gegebenenfalls auch bereit ist
zu bezahlen
wir würden dann zweitens gerne von ihnen
wissen welche verabredungen werden
eigentlich in der europäischen union
getroffen das hat einen sondergipfel der
staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union gegeben sie haben
darüber hier im deutschen bundestag
nicht informiert weder vorher noch
nachher obwohl das eigentlich gute übung
gewesen ist dass so etwas gemacht wird
wenn sie das schon nicht gemacht haben
dann bitte heute wie stellt sich die
europäische union eigentlich den umgang
mit der volksrepublik china vor ich
erwähne tast deshalb weil jedoch nicht
völlig außer betracht lassen können was
dieses große land in dieser krise auf
dieser welt tut da könnte der nächste
große konflikt für die ganze welt drohen
was ist die antwort der europäer auf die
haltung der volksrepublik china die sich
erkennbar nicht bereit findet hier auch
ein klares wort zu finden über diesen
konflikt über diesen krieg der in der
ukraine stattfindet ich habe eine
weitere frage
welche herr bundeskanzler welche
verabredungen werden eigentlich in der
nato getroffen es wird ja in dieser
woche morgen in brüssel einen
sondergipfel der nato geben wie gehen
eigentlich die nato-mitgliedstaaten was
ist die meinung der bundesrepublik
deutschland und ihrer regierung zur
haltung der türkei die türkei beteiligt
sich nicht an den sanktionen gegen
russland wie gehen sie damit um was
machen sie wie wirken sie auf die
türkische regierung ein und welche
haltung nimmt die nato gegenüber ihrem
mitgliedsland türkei ein in dieser frage
auch das ist doch ein punkt der in der
öffentlichkeit einmal dargelegt werden
und schließlich
weitgehend unbemerkt von der deutschen
öffentlichkeit der bundeskanzler hat die
bundesrepublik deutschland zur zeit die
präsidentschaft in der g 7 gruppe auch
dazu soll es ja morgen einen
sondergipfel geben unter beteiligung des
amerikanischen präsidenten was plant die
bundesregierung eigentlich aus dieser
präsidentschaft heraus zu tun ich lese
nun in der zeitung dass ihr
finanzminister mit einem großen
interview ein neues freihandelsabkommen
mit amerika vor schlecht ist das auch
ihre meinung herr bundeskanzler ein
solches freihandelsabkommen zu
verabschieden und wenn es ihre meinung
ist warum haben wir dann wenigstens
nicht jetzt schon das lange
ausverhandelte freihandelsabkommen mit
kanada verabschiedet das liegt seit
jahren auf dem tisch ihr finanzminister
redet über titel ein neues abkommen mit
amerika und diese fraktionen da die spd
und die grünen verweigern bis zum
heutigen tag eine verabschiedung dieses
freihandelsabkommen das wäre doch jetzt
der richtige zeitpunkt ein solches
abkommen zu verabschieden hier im
deutschen bundestag auch zu ratifizieren
damit klar wird auf der welt wir
verstehen diese antwort wir geben eine
klare antwort auf diese neue spaltung
der welt die uns durch den krieg in der
ukraine droht der bundeskanzler ich will
einfach abschließen mit folgendem satz
wenn sie
ich sagen und wir teilen diese
einschätzung dass wir zeugen einer
zeitenwende sind dann müssen sie durch
diese zeitenwende auch sichtbar und
hörbar führen das erwarten wir vom
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland
das war der fraktionschef der union
friedrich merz es ist deutlich zu sehen
dass es nicht leicht werden dürfte die
100 milliarden für die bundeswehr im
grundgesetz zu verankern die zustimmung
der union wird dafür benötigt aber diese
stellt klare bedingungen kein
blankoscheck für die ampel so die
deutliche ansage
nächster redner wird nun bundeskanzler
olaf scholz sein
[Applaus]
das wort für die bundesregierung ertrag
der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren
mit großer tapferkeit und
durchhaltevermögen kämpfen die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine für
ihre heimat
putins offensive steckt fest trotz aller
zerstörung die sie tag für tag anrichtet
und wir so wie unsere freunde und
partner halten zusammen
ich habe noch die worte im ohr die
präsidentin lenz die letzte woche hier
gesprochen hat es ist schwer für uns
ohne die hilfe der welt zu bestehen
deshalb sage ich heute ganz klar
präsident selensky die ukraine kann sich
auf unsere hilfe verlassen
seit kriegsbeginn liefert deutschland
panzer und luftabwehrwaffen ausrüstung
und munition an die ukraine die
europäische union stellt zusätzlich eine
milliarde an militärhilfe bereit
gemeinsam mit unseren internationalen
partnern haben wir sanktionen verhängt
die ihresgleichen suchen über monate
hinweg haben wir sie bis ins kleinste
detail vorbereitet damit sie die
richtigen treffen damit sie wirken
weltweit haben wir für unterstützung
geworben mein ganz besonderer dank gilt
dafür der außenministerin annalena
baerbock
und gesehen die sanktionen wirken
russlands wirtschaft wankt die börse ist
weitgehend geschlossen die währung des
abgestürztes fehlen die wiesn
ausländische unternehmen verlassen zu
hunderten das lacht
doch das ist erst der anfang viele der
härtesten folgen werden sich erst in den
kommenden wochen zeigen und wir schaffen
die sanktionen ständig nach
natürlich
höre ich die stimmen derjenigen die eine
flugverbotszone oder nato
friedenstruppen in der ukraine fordern
so schwer es fällt wir
werden dem nicht nachgeben
in fast 80 jahren nachkriegsgeschichte
haben wir das unvorstellbare erfolgreich
vermieten eine direkte militärische
konfrontation zwischen unserem
westlichen verteidigungsbündnis der nato
und russland
dabei muss es bleiben
viele
vielen bürgern und bürger machen sich
große sorgen weil sie verstehen dass
sich genau dies hinter begriffen wie
flugverbotszone un-friedenstruppen
verbirgt
tag für tag erreichen mich hunderte
besorgter briefe und e mails überall wo
man derzeit mit bürgern und bürgern
spricht begegnet einem früher oder
später die frage
wird es krieg geben auch hier bei uns
auf
diese frage kann es nur eine antwort
geben die nato wird nicht kriegspartei
da sind wir uns mit unseren europäischen
verbündeten und den vereinigten staaten
eine
das ist ein gebot der vernunft alles
andere wäre unverantwortlich
meine damen und herren über jahrzehnte
entdeckt ist unsere abhängigkeit von öl
kohle und gas aus russland gewachsen
wir werden diese abhängigkeit beenden so
schnell wie das nur irgend geht
das aber von einem tag auf den anderen
zu tun hieß unser land und ganz europa
in eine rezession zu stürzen
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze werden in
gefahr ganze industriezweige stünden auf
der kippe
zur wahrheit gehört auch schon die jetzt
beschlossenen sanktionen treffen viele
bürgerinnen und bürger hart und zwar bei
weitem nicht nur unter zapfsäule
sanktionen dürfen die europäischen
staaten nicht härter treffen als die
europäische führung das ist unser die
russische führung das ist unser prinzip
niemandem damit gedient wenn wir
sehenden auges unsere wirtschaftliche
substanz aufs spiel setzen das sehen im
übrigen auch unsere freunde und partner
so mit denen wir diesen gemeinsamen kurs
von beginn an so abgesteckt haben
meine damen und herren die bilder die
uns tag für tag aus der ukraine
erreichen sind kaum auszuhalten bilder
von zerstörten wohnungen zur bomben
krankenhäusern und belagerten städten
von toten soldaten und immer mehr
getöteten und verletzten zivilisten von
frauen und kindern die mit dem wenigen
was sie einpacken konnten vor putins
bomben panzern und raketen fliehen
zugleich haben sie bei uns im land und
über in europa eine überwältigende welle
des mitgefühls und der solidarität
ausgelöst
hilfsorganisationen berichten dass die
spendenbereitschaft in deutschland noch
nie so hoch waren
zehntausende an den fliegenden nicht nur
ihre herzen geöffnet sondern auch ihre
häuser und wohnung und vor allem länder
wie polen tschechien die slowakei
rumänien oder ungarn leisten
außerordentliches das ist ein
das ist ein lichtblick in diesen dunklen
tagen und für diese hilfsbereitschaft
für diese offenherzigkeit sage ich den
bürgerinnen und bürgern hier bei uns in
ganz europa von ganzem herzen danke
rechtlich schafft die eu-richtlinie
klarheit die einen geflüchteten aus der
ukraine vorübergehenden schutz gewährt
das ist gut so
praktisch aber stehen wir vor einer
gewaltigen aufgabe und ich bin dankbar
dass innenministerin nancy faeser sie
entschlossen anpackt herzlichen dank
dafür
es ist die pflicht und schuldigkeit
aller bund länder und gemeinden im sinne
der sache zusammenzuarbeiten anstatt
erst einmal lange über
verantwortlichkeiten zu debattieren
deshalb bin ich froh dass wir uns bei
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz letzte
woche geeinigt haben die offenen fragen
gemeinsam bis zum siebten april zu
klären und ich bin froh dass alle staats
und regierungschefs der eu vor zwei
wochen in wehr sei die bereitschaft
ihrer länder bekräftigt haben
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen und ihre
nachbarn zu entlasten
daran müssen wir uns jetzt alle halten
noch ist völlig unklar wie viele frauen
männer und kinder aus der ukraine bei
uns zuflucht suchen werden wir wissen
nur es werden viele sein
noch lässt sich nicht abschätzen wie
groß der bedarf an humanitärer hilfe und
unterstützung beim wiederaufbau in der
ukraine sein wird oder welche verwerfung
der krieg weltweit verursacht schon
jetzt waren die vereinigten nationen vor
hunger und instabilität aufgrund
steigender lebensmittelpreise
klar ist nur
die flüchtlinge sind hier bei uns
willkommen
und deutschland wird helfen hier bei uns
in europa und in der welt
die bundesregierung ist dazu bereit
zusätzliche maßnahmen zu ergreifen und
ich bin finanzminister christian lindner
sehr dankbar dass er in den kommenden
wochen einen ergänzungs haushalts
ausarbeiten wird um unser land durch
diese schwere zeit zu bringen
noch etwas ist mir wichtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir werden
nichts unversucht lassen bis wieder
frieden herrscht auf unserem kontinent
mit präsident selent ski habe ich mich
immer wieder über die lage und die
nächsten schritte ausgetauscht und auch
mit präsident putin habe ich in den
vergangenen tagen oft lang und intensiv
gesprochen
putin muss die wahrheit hören über den
krieg in der ukraine und diese wahrheit
lautet der krieg zerstört die ukraine
aber mit dem krieg zerstört putin auch
russlands zukunft die passung waffen
müssen schweigen und zwar sofort
ob die laufenden verhandlungen zwischen
der ukraine und russland zum erfolg
führen vermag heute niemand zu sagen
noch steht der beweis aus dass es putin
dabei nicht nur um einen diktat frieden
geht
eins aber steht vollkommen außer frage
über die ukraine verhandeln die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ihr präsident
und seine verhandlungsdelegation und
niemand sonst
alles aber was wird zur unterstützung
der ukraine bei der suche nach einer
politischen lösung beitragen können das
werden wir tun
dass wir europäer dabei eine zentrale
rolle übernehmen halte ich für ganz
entscheidend und zwar nicht nur weil
sich der krieg in der ukraine
geografisch vor unserer haustür abspielt
es geht um europäische werte um
demokratie und freiheit und die stärke
des rechts
diese werte zu erhalten und zu
verteidigen darin liegt die zentrale
aufgabe unseres staates auch hier wirkt
der krieg im osten europas wie ein
brennglas
weil er uns zu vermeintlich 9 in
wahrheit aber längst überfälligen
schwerpunktsetzungen prägt ich spreche
von der entscheidung deutlich mehr in
unsere eigene sicherheit und
verteidigung zu investieren
sicherheit heißt und europäische und
transatlantische so aufzustellen dass
wir uns gegen alle angriffe verteidigen
können das bedeutet europäische
souveränität gerade in der sicherheits-
und verteidigungspolitik im einklang mit
der nato
deutschland wird dazu beitragen
darin liegt eine nationale
kraftanstrengung für alle demokratischen
kräfte
wir wollen daher ganz bewusst ein
sondervermögen bundeswehr errichten und
in unserer verfassung verankern die
ausplanung schon fortgeschritten und
dafür bin ich verteidigungsministerin
christine lambrecht sehr dankbar
danken möchte ich auch allen die bereits
in diesem weg mitzugehen ganz
ausdrücklich auch ihrer fraktion die bei
hermanns über die ausgestaltung werden
wir weiter miteinander reden im sinne
der sache im sinne der sicherheit
unseres landes und der bürgerinnen und
bürger und es ist
und es ist völlig in ordnung dass sie
hier und an anderer stelle dazu ihre
vorstellung mit formulieren es so eine
gemeinsame sache werden die wir für
unser land tun
vier ziele
werden wir mit dem sondervermögen
erreichen erstens alle investitionen
kommen abgesichert im grundgesetz einen
klaren zweck zugute unser bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit
zweitens
wir schaffen langfristige
planungssicherheit und verlässlichkeit
die gerade für die anstehenden
großvorhaben notwendig ist
drittens wir behalten die tragfähigkeit
unserer finanzen im blick einschließlich
der schuldenregel des grundgesetzes und
der maastricht kriterien
und das wichtigste viertens die längst
überfälligen investitionen im
verteidigung sicherheit gehen nicht zu
lasten der dringend nötigen
transformation zu einer klimaneutralen
wirtschaft oder zulasten guter
zukunftsfähiger arbeitsplätze
bezahlbare energie fähre renten und
eines leistungsfähigen
gesundheitssystems
dann machen wir uns nichts vor der
klimawandel schreitet immer weiter voran
die korona pandemie ist noch nicht
vorbei und die digitalisierung hat sich
in den vergangenen zwei jahren noch
einmal rasant beschleunigt mit
auswirkungen auf unseren staat unsere
unternehmen und jede und jeden von uns
ja wir brauchen ein staat der für
stabilität und sicherheit sorgt gerade
jetzt
aber zugleich brauchen wir ein staat der
in die zukunft investiert der an der
seite der bürgerinnen und bürger steht
dass eine zu tun ohne das andere zu
lassen das ist unser anspruch
wir können beides weil deutschland gut
da steht auch im internationalen
vergleich und wir leisten beides weil
wir einen klaren plan für dieses land
haben und für seine zukunft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
angesichts der enormen herausforderungen
die vor uns liegen will ich gar nicht
auf alle politikfelder eingehen in denen
wir die zeichen auf aufbruch stellen
drei große themen aber willig
herausgreifen weil sie die bürgerinnen
und bürger ganz besonders beschäftigen
erstens die energie- und klimapolitisch
ich habe den zielkonflikt schon
beschrieben vor dem wir stehen wir
müssen einerseits bringt unabhängig
werden von russischem öl und gas von
fossilen energieträgern insgesamt und
andererseits brauchen wir verlässliche
und bezahlbare energie
kurzfristig heißt dass wir
sichern uns zusätzliche kapazitäten für
kohle gas und öl dafür bin ich
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
sehr dankbar
wird die petition unsere lieferquellen
und zwar schon in den kommenden monaten
dabei setzen wir auf die vorhandenen
flüssiggas terminals an der
westeuropäischen küste und wir werden
sehr viel schneller als bisher eigene
lng terminals bauen
und schließlich arbeiten wir an einem
gesetz das die großen energiekonzerne
verpflichtet ihre speicher mit
bestimmten mindestmengen zufällt
parallel dazu entlasten wir die
bürgerinnen und bürgern unternehmen ein
erstes paket im umfang von über 15
milliarden euro werden wir in den
kommenden tagen noch einmal deutlich
aufstocken der heizkostenzuschuss wird
verdoppelt und auch bei den gestiegenen
kosten für mobilität werden wir die
bürgerinnen und bürger zusätzlich
entlasten
auch beim europäischen rat morgen und
übermorgen wird es um eine besser
integrierte europäische energiepolitik
gehen um ein gemeinsames vorgehen gegen
versorgungsengpässe und auch über die
hohen preise und spekulative exzesse
werden wir sprechen
ich sage aber auch ganz offen ein
aushebeln von marktmechanismen oder
dauersubventionen gerade auf fossile
energie wird es nicht geben
fiskalisch wäre so etwas nicht
durchzuhalten und ökologisch würden
völlig falsche anreize gesetzt
über die kommenden monate hinaus gedacht
gibt es da nur eine nachhaltige antwort
auf energieabhängigkeit und hohe
energiepreise
erneuerbare energien und
energieeffizienz
unser ziel klimaneutralität in
deutschland bis 2045 ist heute wichtiger
denn je und ich hoffe dass wir nun
wirklich alle an einem strang ziehen
wenn es darum geht genehmigungsverfahren
für neue windparks und
fotovoltaikanlagen energietrassen und
speicher deutlich zu beschleunigen und
energie effizienter zu nutzen
nicht jetzt mal langsam
sondern jetzt erst recht so lautet die
devise
bewegung wollen wir auch in die
internationale klimapolitik bringen
unser ziel als vorsätze der
wirtschaftsstarken demokratien der welt
der g7 ist ein offener kooperativer
klima klum es geht darum mit den
ambitionierten gemeinsame standards für
klimafreundliches wirtschaften zu
etablieren anstatt auf die langsamsten
zu wahren so entsteht ein markt der
klimaschutz belohnt anstatt ihn zum
standortnachteil zu machen
der zweite aspekt den ich ansprechen
möchte die wir kolleginnen kollegen ist
unser weg aus der korona pandemie seit
deutschland vor ziemlich genau zwei
jahren zum ersten mal in den knock down
gegangen ist hat kein anderes thema die
bürgerinnen bürger so sehr beschäftigt
und belastet fast 130 tausend menschen
sind seither an corona verstorben
viele weitere kämpfen mit den folgen der
infektion
gesundheitlich wirtschaftlich und sozial
und trotz alledem sind wir insgesamt
besser durch die krise gekommen als
viele andere länder
das ist kein zufall
wir verdanken dass den bürgerinnen und
bürgern unseres landes den pflegekräften
in den kliniken und pflegeeinrichtungen
den ärzten und rettungssanitätern die
seit nun 24 monaten an vorderster front
gegen das virus kämpfen bis zur
erschöpfung und darüber hinaus
den schülerinnen und schüler den
lehrerinnen erziehern und eltern die
nerven zehrende monate hinter sich haben
zwischen unterrichtsausfall
homeschooling home office und schule
unter pandemie bedingungen und natürlich
auch den millionen bürgerinnen und
bürgern die sich an die krone regeln
gehalten haben die sich haben impfen
lassen die auf vieles verzichtet haben
was unser leben schön und lebenswert
macht ich finde es ist höchste zeit in
allen dafür noch einmal zu sagen danke
doch damit ist es nicht getan
wir werden den weg aus der krise
solidarisch zu ende gehen deshalb haben
wir den zugang zur grundsicherung
erleichtert die wirtschaftshilfen und
die sonderregeln zum kurzarbeitergeld
verlängert so ist der deutsche
arbeitsmarkt stabil durch die pandemie
gekommen die wirtschaft kommt langsam
wieder in schwung und kann die vollen
auftragsbücher abarbeiten auch weil
fachkräfte eben nicht entlassen worden
das ist gut
auch mit blick auf die belastung die der
krieg in der ukraine für die wirtschaft
mit sich bringt und bringen wird
in fast allen staaten um uns herum sind
die korona beschränkung inzwischen
gelockert oder nahezu komplett
aufgehoben worden
auch der bundestag hat das
infektionsschutzgesetz letzte woche
angepasst es ermöglicht weitere
lockerung die länder halten halten aber
zugleich die möglichkeit einschränkungen
in kraft zu setzen wenn die lage das
erfordert
als bundesregierung bleiben wir
umsichtig denn nichts wäre schlimmer als
die mühsam erreichten erfolge aufs spiel
zu setzen
für mich heißt das vor allem wir werden
alles dafür tun dass eine neue
infektionsfälle unser land im herbst
nicht wieder zum stillstand bringt dann
vielleicht mit einer virusvariante die
viel gefährlicher ist als mikro
um ein solches derby zu vermeiden
brauchen wir die impf nachweispflicht
und ich bitte sie alle liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen lassen sie uns diesen
schritt in den nächsten wochen gemeinsam
gehen er führt uns aus der pandemie wir
alle sind teil der gesellschaft und in
einer gesellschaft erfordert erfordert
freiheit für alle auch solidarität von
an
dieser gedanke liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen geht weit über die pandemie
hinaus für uns liegen enorme aufgaben
die wirtschaftliche transformation
voranbringen die klimakrise in den griff
bekommen demografischen wandel gestalten
frieden in europa sichern all das wird
uns nur gelingen wenn wir als
gesellschaft solidarisch zusammenhalten
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt zu
stärken
das ist das dritte große handlungsfeld
der bundesregierung die bürger bürger
müssen spüren jeder und jede einzelne
zählt mein beitrag meine anstrengung
wird wertgeschätzt
zentrale ausdruck dafür sind faire
anständige löhne darum hat die
bundesregierung auch als eines ihrer
ersten vorhaben die erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro auf den weg
gebracht am ersten oktober tritt er in
kraft
wenn wir über faire löhne auskömmlichen
bezahlbare mieten oder eine gute
absicherung bei krankheit und
pflegebedürftigkeit reden dann reden wir
nicht über staatliche geschenke sondern
über den kitt der unser land
zusammenhält
um die enorme herausforderung unserer
zeit zu bewältigen brauchen wir diesen
zusammenhang liebe kolleginnen kollegen
einen gedanken will ich noch hinzufügen
alle herausforderungen die vor uns
liegen bewältigen wir umso besser wenn
wir sie gemeinsam mit unseren freunden
und partnern in europa und der welt
angeht in diesem geist kommen morgen die
staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union der nato und auf
meine einladung hin auch der g7 zu einem
außergewöhnlichen gipfeltreffen in
brüssel zusammen
auf den tag genau 65 jahre nach der
unterzeichnung der römischen verträge
werden wir der welt zeigen wir stehen
zusammen
der stimmen ab und entscheiden über die
nächsten schritte gemeinsam
selten war die geschlossenheit der
europäischen union der schulterschluss
innerhalb der nato und die einigkeit der
g7 so groß wie heute und ich bin
präsident beiden sehr dankbar dass er
dies mit seiner reise nach brüssel
unterstreicht diese geschlossenheit
bleibt unser größtes fund im einsatz für
frieden freiheit und demokratie
unsere bündnisse und allianzen werden
diese bewährungsprobe bestehen mehr noch
sie werden gestärkt aus ihr hervorgehen
geschlossen wie nie werden wir in den
kommenden monaten die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der nato stärken
und geschlossen wie nie werden dem
europäischen rat morgen und übermorgen
eine neue europäische
sicherheitsstrategie annehmen den
strategischen kompass damit gehen wir
einen weiteren schritt in richtung
europäischer souveränität wir erleben
gerade
welche dynamik die zeitenwende auch auf
europäischer ebene mit sich bringt das
werden wir nutzen
der sicherheit in europa will der kommt
gar nicht umhin die krisen resilienz der
eu deutlich zu stärken in der
wirtschafts- und europapolitik und
energiepolitik aber auch bei neuen
technologien oder im zeitraum und wer
mit strategischen blick auf die
landkarte europas schaut der muss doch
alles daran setzen dass wir die länder
des westlichen balkan zu unterstützen
damit sie möglichst bald der
europäischen union beitreten können
dass wir angesichts der tragweite
solcher entscheidungen auch unsere
entscheidungsmechanismen innerhalb der
eu anpassen müssen liegt auf der hand
auch da möchte ich bewegung hinein
bringen
meine damen und herren große krisen sind
immer auch ein anstoß zu aufbruch und
verändern gerade erleben wir dass trotz
oder vielleicht gerade wegen des
schreckens den der krieg in der ukraine
auslöst
politische weichen werden neu gestellt
in deutschland und europa der rückhalt
in der bevölkerung dafür ist groß weil
die bürgerinnen und bürger spüren ohne
frieden ist alles nichts
freiheit und demokratie sind plötzlich
keine abstrakten begriffe mehr sondern
etwas das es zu verteidigen lohnt
und überall in unserem land wird
solidarität sichtbar millionen menschen
spenden sie gehen zu friedenskundgebung
sie helfen den geflüchteten aus der
ukraine
mir macht das mut weil es zeigt in der
krise wachsen wir über uns hinaus weil
es zeigt wie viel gutes in unserem land
steckt und weil es zeigt was wir
gemeinsam bewegen können schönen dank
dieser schreiben rede des bundeskanzlers
mit einem ausblick apotheker ohne
klimaschutz betonte die solidarität mit
der ukraine ein militärisches eingreifen
der nato lehnte er erneut ab die nato
werde keine tricks partei so chance auf
einem stopp der russischen
gaslieferungen nach deutschland lehnt er
ab aber er werde alles versuchen diesen
typ zu beenden antworten auf die fragen
von friedrich merz nach dem
langfristigen 2 prozent zu und den
details der waffenlieferung gab es
jedoch nicht
es folgt nun als nächster redner der
fraktionsvorsitzende der afd timo pop an
die lokale hat das wort für die fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe landsleute
herr bundeskanzler eines hat ihre rede
eigentlich deutlich gezeigt deutschland
ist absolut im ungleichgewicht
mittlerweile ist das überall sichtbar
wovor wir sie ihre vorgänger werte
bundesregierung lange gewehrt haben die
deutsche gesellschaft ist gespalten
gespalten in jene die erst an der
tankstelle sehen dass sie erleben nun
mehr geld kostet und solche die schon
lange kein auto mehr besitzen und
zukünftig auch noch für die freiheit
frieren soll nach allen wahlversprechen
der spd um einen höheren mindestlohn
stehen die bundesbürger nun vor den
scherben der illusion von wohlstand und
sicherheit und das haben abschließend
sie zu verantworten herr bundeskanzler
auch ihr haushalt
auch hier haushalt den wir hier beraten
muss eben erwirtschaftet werden und das
machen alle die tagtäglich mit ihrer
arbeit zur wertschöpfung beitragen
einige von ihnen kennen das vielleicht
noch und wissen was das bedeutet werte
kollegen mehr als zwei jahre haben wir
den bürgern viel abverlangt rechtlich
fragwürdige maßnahmen zur bekämpfung des
corona virus haben existenzen gekostet
und wohlstand gefährdet kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen betrifft
das ebenso wie das handwerk doch es sind
genau diese menschen die für den erhalt
unserer sozialen sicherungssysteme
sorgen von da auch von ihnen herr
bundeskanzler kein wort an diese
menschen und denen ist klar am anfang
einer jeden investition muss es eben ein
kassensturz geben das gehört zur
ordentliche haushaltsplanung dazu die
regierenden müssen den bürgern erklären
können wie viel sie wofür ausgeben und
vor allen in weshalb und noch viel
wichtiger muss das symbol unseres landes
passieren und nicht allein im raum
schnitt berlin plausibel erscheinen sie
müssen eine vision für deutschland
vorlegen davon war heute kein wort und
die muss sich auch in den wurf eines
bundeshaushaltes abbilden sie aber
sie aber formulieren von digitalisierung
und meinen breitband reden von sozialer
gerechtigkeit und erzeugen genau das
gegenteil nämlich spaltung denn so
wichtig und die digitalisierung von
prozessen sein muss die wohnung wärmt
das eben nicht und die allgemeinbildung
zukünftige generationen wurde bislang
auch nicht allzu positiv davon
beeinflusst deutschland meine damen und
herren fehlen facharbeiter und
handwerker ohne diese können technische
anderen beispielsweise im bereich der
digitalen infrastruktur nicht aufgebaut
und auch nicht gewartet werden dieser
zustand führt nicht zu digitaler
souveränität sondern zu einseitigen
abhängigkeiten es muss zuallererst eine
tragfähige infrastruktur gesichert
werden in den bereichen verkehr
kommunikation gesundheit bildung usw und
die beispiele sind nur eine auswahl und
zeigen eigentlich gleichzeitig wie viele
baustellen wie eigentlich vor uns
herschieben die unterschiede zwischen
ländlichen gebieten und den
ballungsgebieten neben in rasendem tempo
zu es ist eben das beschriebene
ungleichgewicht was sie mit ihrer
politischen arbeit tagtäglich verstärken
und versprochen haben insbesondere die
genossen von der spd im wahlkampf des
letzten jahres sehr viel zentral war die
anhebung des mindestlohns aus heutiger
sicht deckt diese erhöhung nicht einmal
mehr die kosten der inflation
nahrungsmittel kraftstoffe waren nur der
anfang mittlerweile folgen waren
knappheit und ist droht der stillstand
der verarbeitenden industrien aufgrund
von fehlenden rohstoffen und welche
maßnahmen ergreift eigentlich die
bundesregierung der bundesfinanzminister
legte gestern seinen haushaltsentwurf
vor nichts konkretes war enthalten auch
heute in den bundeskanzler nichts
konkretes der schon bei der präsentation
überholt waren sie werden
bundesregierung sie betreiben die
politik der inflation in diesem land
und sie verstecken ihr desinteresse an
deutschland und unseren bürgern nicht
einmal mehr stück für stück lassen sie
ihre masken mittlerweile fallen die idee
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft wurde
zugunsten einer ideologisch rot grün
gefärbten staatspolitik begraben bestes
beispiel dafür ist der besuch des
bundesministers robert habeck in katar
meine damen und herren das muss man sich
einmal vorstellen
weil die bundesregierung helfen möchte
russland wirtschaftlich und ökonomisch
auszuhungern sollen wir auf günstige
erdgaslieferungen durch nord stream 1
und 2 verzichten und der
wirtschaftsminister verhandelt die
lieferung von arabischen gas verstöße
gegen menschenrechte scheint plötzlich
keine rolle mehr zu spielen der geehrte
damen und herren mehr hat doppelmoral
der bundesregierung gibt es wohl doch
kaum
und herr bundeskanzler
ihre politik markiert ein zeitalter der
extreme der extrempositionen sich frei
von russischem gas machen zu wollen ist
spiegelbildlich mit dem ziel zu sehen
von schirokow wett beide sind ideologie
getriebene trug bilder die in
unendlichen ressourcen verschwenden und
ihr ziel wenn überhaupt nur ansatzweise
überhaupt erreichen zu können was also
ist denn ihr ziel herr bundeskanzler das
haben sie auch heute nicht klar zum
ausdruck gebracht wohin möchten sie
eigentlich unser land führen im moment
jedenfalls treiben sie den keim immer
tiefer in unsere gesellschaft den
bürgern wird zb ein freedom day
versprochen und sie erhalten erneut ein
föderales regelchaos ich stimme ihnen ja
zu dass politik immer in gewissen
ausgleich auch bestrebt sein sollte
allerdings muss dieser ausgleich auch
bei der basis der wähler und natürlich
unsere bürger ankommen sie aber
blockieren die zukunft unseres landes
meine damen und herren
weiterhin im haushalt des bundeskanzlers
findet sich der geschäftsbereich
ostdeutschland davon von ihnen heute
herr bundeskanzler kein einziges wort
wie sie wissen teilen weite gebiete der
neuen bundesländer das gleiche schicksal
wie zum beispiel gebiet der nordrhein
westfalen oder auch im salat verpackt
wird es unter dem schlagwort
strukturwandel mein lieblingswort es
meint jedoch die deindustrialisierung
weiter landstriche die probleme damit
sind bekannt werden jedoch gerade jetzt
eben nicht angepackt gelder aus
strukturfonds programm werden in kultur
und prestige objekte investiert anstelle
davon wertschöpfende arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen man sieht es wirklich in
ostdeutschland überall wenn im
tennisheim gebaut radwege aber für
bestehende betriebe ist ihm kein geld da
wir müssen in förderung für
wertschöpfende betriebe und auch
arbeitsplätze schaffen und das hat die
vorhergehende bundesregierung aber auch
diese komplett verpasst
und die debatte um energiesicherheit
liegt vor uns auf dem tisch es handelt
sich dabei um die grundversorgung
unserer bürger und unserer wirtschaft
und habe wissen sie eigentlich wie lange
es dauert bis man großmaschinen oder
auch kraftwerke in betrieb genommen hat
denn wenn das so wäre und sie es wüssten
würden sie mit der real gefangen gefahr
eines blackouts ganz anders umgehen auch
hier wieder die ideologische verblendung
in einer politisch und existenziell
wichtigen debatte sie wissen es
alternative energieträger sind eben
nicht grundlastfähig eine debatte um
moderne gas- und kohlekraftwerke ist in
diesem zusammenhang längst überfällig
und gefehlt
den östlichen bundesländern wird der
strukturwandel eines jedenfalls nicht
gewähren wohlstand sicherheit und ein
wirtschaftliches umfeld in denen sich
gerade die junge generation niederlassen
können und die ohnehin verfrühte abkehr
vom letzten fossilen energieträger in
deutschland der braunkohle bis 2030 muss
jetzt eben revidiert werden ja und das
sage ich ganz bewusst ja es ist wichtig
auch über naturschutz zu reden aber das
wohlergehen der menschen das muss hier
priorität haben und ich wiederhole mich
wir sprechen hier von der
grundversorgung und die muss ein staat
garantieren ebenso eine staatliche
aufgabe ist das thema innere sicherheit
jetzt werden stimmen laut mann soll der
kriegsflüchtlinge auf die bundesländer
im osten verteilen dort leben ja sie
sich weniger menschen habe ich alles
schon mal gehört 2015 auch hier wird
wieder der zweite vor dem ersten schritt
gemacht zuerst müssen wir erstmal wissen
und darauf kommt es an vor faeser wer
kommt den eigentlichen und sala diese
litt menschen müssen registriert werden
in keinem anderen land der erde mit 192
staaten kann man einfach ein lesen ohne
registriert und kontrolliert worden zu
sein in deutschland ist das möglich und
können sie so die frage muss gewährt wie
können sie so überhaupt für sicherheit
der kriegsflüchtlinge und auch der
anderen bürger in deutschland
garantieren diese politik herr scholz
ist eben nicht zu ende gedacht und meine
damen und herren wir müssen unter allen
umständen verhindern dass konfliktherde
auf deutschland übergreifen und ja wir
haben krieg in europa aber wir befinden
uns nicht im krieg mit irgend einen
start und das soll auch so bleiben wir
lassen uns auch nicht in einen dritten
weltkrieg hinein ziehen nicht durch
worte und auch nicht durch
versprechungen wie beispielsweise
waffenlieferungen in das kriegsgebiet
der ukraine wert der bundesregierung
eskalieren sie nicht ständig höher weder
500 millionen euro noch 1 milliarden
euro für waffen werden den krieg in der
ukraine
enden vielmehr wird durch diese
fehlgeleitete politik auch noch blut an
den händen der deutschen bürger kleben
das darf nicht sein und eine
sozialdemokratisch geführte
bundesregierung russell zumindest
indirekt in europa mit dem säbel und hat
hier seine bürger nach vier monaten kaum
noch mehr als inflation neue schulden
und soziale verarmung im angebot dass
herr bundeskanzler werden unsere kinder
und enkelkinder ihr ganzes leben
abtragen müssen
und lassen sie mich in diesem
zusammenhang kurz auf die
finanzierungspläne der bundeswehr
eingehen wofür wird der
verteidigungsetat eigentlich seit jahren
verwendet diese frage muss man sich ja
jetzt bei dieser debatte stellen hier
wird nämlich nur der mangel verwaltet
den schon die letzten drei
verteidigungsminister identifiziert
hatten und herzig muss in ihrer rede die
ich ag angehört drücke ich sagen was das
für die zur bundeswehr gesagt hatten das
ist ja schon fast kabarett sie waren ja
vielleicht 13 jahre nicht da aber
vielleicht sollten sich mal mit frau von
der leyen an einen tisch setzen wofür
das geld eigentlich ausgegeben wurde für
beraterverträge wo das geld zum fenster
rausgeschmissen das hat auch die cdu mit
zu verantworten und
werde kollegen die bundeswehr gehört zu
deutschland und wir brauchen eine
verteidigungsarmee die sowohl materiell
als auch personell gut ausgestattet ist
allerdings sollte man sich wirklich
fragen weshalb die debatte gerade jetzt
mit so viel energie betrieben wird denn
eines steht auch fest auch die
unreflektierte summe von 100 milliarden
euro wird der lage der bundeswehr
innerhalb
kürzester zeit im nicht verbessern neue
und moderne waffensysteme brauchen
zuallererst 1 menschen menschen die
diese auch bedienen können und wie soll
die neue bundeswehr eigentlich personal
aussehen auch das muss ja mal debattiert
und diskutiert denn bevor man über
weitere kosten und weitere summen
spricht werden die neuen generationen
doch ihr vater dann eigentlich
verteidigen können und vor allen dingen
wollen und lassen sie mich dazu was
persönliches sagen ich habe drei kinder
davon zwei söhne und ich frage sie haben
ja auch kinder und enkelkinder würden
sie herrn lauterbach
ja
verteidigungsminister lamprecht frau
berbalk 1 linda ein harbeck und ein
scholz ihre kinder anvertrauen dieser
bundesregierung
die ja das kann ich nicht und ich würde
das sage ich auch ganz ehrlich meine
kinder auch nicht an märz an vertrauen
denn mit herrn merz als bundeskanzler
während wir schon im dritten weltkrieg
und hier geht es nämlich genau um das
über das wir hier im bundestag auch
reden müssen hier geht es um identität
um deutsche tugenden um ehrlichkeit
fleiß und das braucht die zukünftige
generation und vor allen dingen
vaterlandsliebe das muss gewährleistet
sein den mentalitäten lassen sich zum
glück nicht auf knopfdruck ändern und
verstehen sie mich bitte nicht falsch
aber ich würde mich freuen wenn sich
konflikte allein durch gespräche lösen
ließen und ich meine dass jetzt die zeit
der diplomatie erst begonnen hat und
deshalb schicken sie diplomaten anstatt
waffen agieren sie als vermittler denn
nur so schafft man frieden vielen dank
das war timo kubala von der afg er warf
der regierung vor keine vision für die
zukunft des landes zu haben die
regierung schiebe zu viele baustellen
vor sich her bei der infrastruktur bei
der digitalisierung
wirtschaftsminister habeck warf er
doppelmoral vor mit seinem besuch in
katar
ideologischen kanzlers waffenlieferung
an die ukraine lehnt die traditionell
eher russlandfreundlichen
nächste rednerin ist nun die
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis
90/grüne katharina dröge
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe gestern abend einen artikel
gelesen geschrieben von den letzten zwei
internationalen journalisten die bis vor
kurzem noch aus mario pohl berichtet
haben sie haben geschrieben wir sind
geblieben obwohl es lebensgefährlich war
weil die welt wissen muss was hier
passiert weil die welt wissen muss wie
die wahrheit aussieht und sie haben
recht es ist unser aller aufgabe über
die wahrheit in diesem krieg zu sprechen
auch wenn sie kaum auszuhalten ist auch
wenn die bilder die geschichten die wir
über diesen krieg erfahren so in
unerträglich sind dass man kaum darüber
sprechen kann über die kinder die im
bombenhagel sterben über geburtskliniken
die geschaffen werden und so viele tote
dass sie nicht einmal mehr ordentlich
begraben werden können über all das
müssen wir sprechen die welt muss die
wahrheit wissen denn nichts fürchtet
putin mehr
deshalb unterdrückter phase mit allen
mittel immer härter immer autoritärer
die informationsmöglichkeiten für sein
eigenes volk deshalb spielt er jeden in
russland weg der es wagt einen anderen
gedanken zu formulieren
und nichts fürchten autorisierte mehr
als die idee von demokratie und freiheit
auch deshalb versucht putin gerade die
ukraine zu zerstören doch an dieser
stelle das sage ich ganz klar hat putin
den krieg schon längst verloren die idee
von demokratie und freiheit wie ist so
stark die kann man nicht weggucken die
ist so stark wie kann man auch nicht
wegsperren das beweisen die vielen
mutigen menschen in seinem land jeden
tag und es ist unser aller aufgabe hier
in europa dies zu verteidigen und zu den
wenigen positiven erfahrungen in dieser
dunklen in dieser grausamkeit gehört es
dass die eu und das die demokratischen
länder in europa ist geschafft haben
viel gemeinsam zu stehen es ist gut zu
sehen mit welcher geschlossenheit mit
welcher entschlossenheit die
europäischen staaten direkt nachkriegs
gewinn gemeinsam mit ihren verbündeten
ein hartes ein scharfes wirtschaft
sanktionspaket auf den weg gebracht
haben einem ausmaß dass wir noch niemals
geschlossen haben
mit sanktionen die sanktionierung der
russischen zentralbank über die wir
vorher noch nicht einmal diskutiert
hatten diese sanktionen werden die
russische wirtschaft hart treffen sie
leidet jetzt schon stark darunter aber
es ist natürlich auch wichtig dass wir
weiter an zusätzlichen sanktionen
arbeiten jeden tag auch mit blick auf
die fossilen importe aus russland
und ich bin extrem froh dass die
europäische union ist in dieser krise
geschafft hat zusammenzustehen in einer
frage in der sie in der vergangenheit
immer gescheitert ist dass sie es
geschafft hat jetzt solidarisch zusammen
zu stehen bei der aufnahme der vielen
geflüchteten die aus der ukraine zu uns
kommt dass wir einmal gemeinsam gesagt
haben wir helfen schnell und
unbürokratisch wir kriegen das gemeinsam
hin
und dass das funktioniert das liegt auch
an der großartige hilfsbereitschaft der
menschen überall in europa menschen die
einfach zu hauptbahnhöfen gehen und den
erschöpften familien die dort ankommen
einen platz in ihrer eigenen wohnung
anbieten
ehrenamtlichen zivilgesellschaft
feuerwehr thw die schon während corona
so viel geleistet haben und die auch
jetzt wieder da sind ganz
selbstverständlich und helfen und
infrastruktur und unterstützung aufbauen
ihnen allen gehört unser dank
es ist unser job diese hilfe jetzt
besser zu koordinieren ist es unser job
die kommunen hierbei zu unterstützen und
es ist auch unser job die länder
innerhalb europas zu unterstützen die
hierbei jetzt an ihre grenzen stoßen und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass annalena
baerbock dass unsere aus ministerin
gerade noch mal betont hat das ist eine
luftbrücke braucht innerhalb der
europäischen union um zu einer
gemeinsamen solidarischen unterbringung
und verteilung der geflüchteten menschen
zu kommen
und liebe kollegen umzulegen doch was
putin gerade macht das erschüttert ganz
europa es ist ein angriffskrieg der
unser aller sicherheit infrage stellt
uns in so einer krassen situation da
muss politik in der lage sein
entscheidungen neu zu bewerten und dazu
gehört für uns auch die entscheidung
über investitionen in unsere eigene und
in die europäische sicherheit in dieser
gefährlichen zeit in der die sicherheit
in europa so herausgefordert ist ist es
sinnvoll auch als deutsche
bundesregierung die aufgaben in unsere
eigene sicherheit deutlich zu erhöhen
und deshalb ist es richtig ein
sondervermögen zu schaffen außerhalb der
schuldenbremse dass diese investition
ermöglicht
aber herr merz ich habe ihre rede werden
zugehört und sie hat mich in teilen auf
erschüttert es hat mich erschüttert dass
sie es geschafft haben so lange an
diesem rednerpult zu stehen und keinen
einzigen satz über die situation der
menschen in der ukraine zu verlieren das
wäre jede verantwortung sie will sich
finde es unangemessen dass sie das nicht
getragen haben
auch bei dem worüber wir gesprochen
haben habe ich mich gefragt warum das so
verwirrt war dass sie ausgerechnet der
fdp vorwerfen dass in 16 jahren in denen
die cdu das verteilt und die csu das
verteidigungsministerium verantwortet
haben dass sie es gar nicht geschafft
haben die bundeswehr mit ausreichende
ausrüstung zu unterstützen in einer zeit
in der wolfgang schäuble finanzminister
war es der fdp vorzuwerfen dass sie es
nicht gebacken gekriegt haben das fand
ich eigentlich
und ich sage ihnen auf gehabt wir müssen
mehr investieren in die sicherheit und
wir müssen mehr investieren in die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr
es waren ihre beschaffungsplan die dazu
geführt haben dass sie jetzt so schlecht
aufgestellt ist aber wir müssen
sicherheit eben auch breiter definieren
sicherheit im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert bedeutet eben auch gerüstet
zu sein gegen cyberangriffe das ist
moderne sicherheitspolitik und
sicherheit eben auch unsere
partnerländer sicherheit zu unterstützen
wir leben in einer global vernetzten
welt da kann man sicherheit nicht mehr
national denken und ich kann es mir
eigentlich nur also ein bisschen
störrisch erklären dass sie das was wir
gemeinsam im rahmen der nato als
sicherheitsbegriff verankert haben
vereinbart haben worauf sie in der
haushaltsplanung in den sechs letzten 16
jahren gestützt haben dass sie jetzt das
hier in frage stellen wollen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
es gesagt in einer zeit die so krass ist
wie diese muss man in der lage sein
fragen neu zu bewerten und zu neuen
schlüssel zu kommen und deswegen der
märz habe ich mich auch gewundert dass
wird jeder rede keinen einzigen satz zum
thema energie souveränität gehört haben
wir sind in vollem maße abhängig von
russischem gas kommt kohle und öl und es
ist die politik der union in den letzten
16 jahren gewesen die uns in diese
fatale abhängigkeit geführt haben wir
hätten in dieser sitzung nichts
eigentlich gemacht hätten mit dem ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien und der
energieeffizienz
was wir im letzten von ihnen immer
wieder gehört haben zuallererst bei dem
projekt nord stream 2 war projekte mit
russland das ist nur wirtschaft und ich
sage ihnen davon müssen sie sich einmal
und schlussendlich verabschieden man
kann keine geschäfte mit autoritären und
totalität inklusiven machen ohne das ist
eine außenpolitische bedeutung hat man
kann sich nicht abhängig machen von
fossilen import und ohne doch ist ein
extrem hohes sicherheitsrisiko hat und
ja ich weiß warum sie jetzt hier
schreiben ich gebe ihnen darauf eine
ganz klare antwort in dieser situation
in der wir so abhängig sind von
fossilien aus russland in der situation
in der putin kinder bombardiert müssen
wir alles dafür tun um unabhängig zu
werden von russischen gas und weil auf
den weltmärkten gerade nichts anderes zu
kaufen ist muss man es auch in katar und
saudi arabien kaufen aber das heißt eben
auch wenn ernst meint mit dieser politik
dann muss man jetzt den weg gehen und
unabhängig werden von forcieren dann
kann man nicht machen weil sie die ganze
zeit erzielt dafür den kohleausstieg
treten atomausstiegs zurückgehen müssen
dass in bayern und in nordrhein
westfalen
die ausbau der windenergie zu blockieren
das ist alles eine politik die den ernst
der lage die die zeichen der zeit nicht
verstanden hat
sie haben in dieser rede kein einziges
wort zum thema energieeffizienz gesagt
sie haben diese rede keine perspektive
aufgezeigt ich frage mich ganz ehrlich
warum hat die union mehr angst vor
wärmepumpen der energetischen
gebäudesanierung und von windrädern als
von der abhängigkeit von autoritären
regime diese antwort müssen sie geben
ex tag in ein diese regierung wird einen
aufruf schaffen wir werden dafür sorgen
dass wir ernst machen mit dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien dass wir auf jedem
dach in diesem land irgendwann eine
solarzelle haben dass wir ernst machen
mit der reduzierung von der abhängigkeit
von gas und ich würde mich freuen wenn
die cdu nicht die ganze zeit auf der
bremse stehen würde und
er hat sie haben ja auch so eine
grundsatzfrage zum haushalt gestellt die
haben gesagt warum reagieren wir
sozialpolitisch nicht auf die lage
derzeit vielleicht ist ihnen den gang
dass der finanzminister schon jetzt
einen ergänzungs haushalt angekündigt
hat weil es notwendig ist die menschen
zu entlasten und einen tag vor eintritt
russland in den krieg haben wir ein
paket in höhe von 13 milliarden euro auf
den weg gebracht mit einer breiten
entlastung von der abschaffung oder der
finanzierung der eeg umlage aus dem
bundeshaushalt über die anhebung des
grundfreibetrags bei der
einkommenssteuer über die anhebung des
betrags war der grundsicherung in form
eines einmal zuschlagen kinderzuschlag
all das haben wir jetzt schon auf den
weg gebracht um die menschen in diesem
land zu unterstützen aber als richtig
und das sagen
klar die menschen brauchen weitere
entlastung denn schon jetzt steigen die
gaspreise enorm schon jetzt ist damit zu
rechnen dass eine durchschnittliche
familie in diesem jahr mehrkosten bei
den gaspreisen von 1000 euro und mehr
haben wird das ist eine belastung bis in
die breite der gesellschaft der reinen
darauf wird diese koalition antworten
geben im rahmen eines ergänzung des
haushaltes breit sozial gerecht und
ökologisch nachhaltig und ich würde mich
freuen wenn die opposition diese letzten
zwei schwachstellen irgendwann beenden
wird und in wenig mit uns auch gehen
würde
für katharina dröge ist die gute
botschaft in diesen dunklen zeiten dass
man die idee von demokratie und freiheit
nicht wegbomben könne und dass die eu
zusammen stehe es sei jetzt dringend
nötig die unterbringung der flüchtlinge
besser zu koordinieren aber auch mehr in
die bundeswehr zu investieren dazu
gehört zu begrünen auch das thema
cybersicherheit ob das dann mit dem 100
milliarden finanziert wird dürfte zu
einem der künftigen streitthemen werden
es folgt nun die papas
fraktionsvorsitzender der linken kollege
dietmar bartsch hat das wort für die
linke
präsidentin meine damen und herren es
ist still geworden
nicht in der ukraine
dort tobt seit 28 tagen der
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg wladimir
putins gegen die zivilbevölkerung gegen
frauen und kinder dieser angriff hat
einen präsidenten zu einem
kriegsverbrecher gemacht aber still
geworden meine damen und herren es ist
auch um die ampel sie haben geschwiegen
nach der ansprache des ukrainischen
präsidenten geht im parlament das war
der regierung und die deutschen
bundestag unwürdig still ist es auch
geworden
als wirtschaftsminister habe in katar
über menschenrechte geredet hat ganz
demütig hat er dort eine langfristige
energie partnerschaft erbeten und das
ist das land katar wo die
außenministerin damals allerdings noch
nicht außenministerin die fußball-wm
wegnehmen wollte weil die taliban im
emirat ihrer heimat gefunden haben und
weil die arbeiter auf den wm baustellen
mit füßen getreten werden wie der ball
auf dem rasen mit den macht man keine
geschäfte katharina dröge was für eine
doppelmoral das ist werte die leichte
außenpolitik der eine autokrat muss
runter und der andere kommt drauf machen
wir uns endlich unabhängig von dieser
unerträglichen energieabhängigkeit das
ist doch der weg massive investitionen
in wasserstoff energetische
gebäudesanierung in erneuerbare energien
in die energieeffizienz aber da lässt
vier haushalten zu wünschen übrig das
alles viel zu wenig meine damen und
herren sehr groß waren die ankündigung
der ampel im letzten jahr der
möglichkeitsraum habe sich erweitert hat
christian linder gemacht großes können
geleistet werden robert habeck gesagt
sie klangen ziemlich großspurig wie die
fußballmannschaft in der
saisonvorbereitung aber mit dem anpfiff
und mit dem ersten pflichtspiel mit dem
druck der realität geht nicht viel mehr
sie spielen fehlpässe sie streiten den
term kriegen kaum einen erfolgreichen
abschluss hin ich weiß auch es eine
besondere situation wir haben kriegt
diesen furchtbaren wir haben die
pandemie die herausforderungen des
klimawandels die schreiende soziale
ungerechtigkeit aber auf die tief
liegenden probleme unseres landes die
sozialen verwerfungen und
gesellschaftlichen entfremdung da haben
sie keine antworten die krisen dieser
wochen überfordern sie meine damen und
herren in der ukraine bringen sie den
präsidenten gegen sich auf bei der
pandemie bringen sie die bundesländer
gegen sich auf und bei den steigenden
preisen insbesondere bei lebensmitteln
und energie bringen sie die bürgerinnen
und bürger gegen sich auf weil sie
streiten anstatt zu handeln diese 100
tage ampel sind ein maß an ernüchterung
bisher sie hatten doch alle drei im
wahlkampf versprochen entlastung bei den
kleinen und mittleren unternehmen jetzt
feiern sie ihre entlastung aber sie sind
keine entlastungs koalition sie sind
eine belastungs koalition selten haben
die bürger unter 1 9 unter einer neuen
regierung in so kurzer zeit so viel
kaufkraft verloren das ist doch die
wahrheit die kaufkraft zielt und nicht
einzelne entlastungsmaßnahmen das ist
die wahrheit die inflation ist so hoch
wie seit jahrzehnten nicht die preise
für lebensmittel für energie für sprit
die gehen durch die decke meine damen
und herren und nicht wenige bürgerinnen
und bürger unseres landes sehen sich zu
der entscheidung gezwungen heizen heizen
oder einkaufen ist dass der respekt von
dem sie immer gesprochen haben nein
meine damen und herren das ist
respektlos diese preisexplosion
produziert millionen verlierer familien
kinder rentner und ein gewinner was
finanzminister christian linder für
dieses jahr gibt es allein 20 milliarden
mehreinnahmen über die höheren preise
über die mehrwertsteuer aber das ist das
geld der bürgerinnen und bürger folgen
sie doch endlich unseren europäischen
nachbarn und entlasten sie die
bürgerinnen und bürger bei lebensmitteln
und bei energie zehn länder haben da was
auch den weg gebracht unterschiedliche
initiativen und sie kündigen ankündigen
an und machen mini maßnahmen das reicht
nicht die ampel diskutiert widerspricht
sich aber die unternehmen oder die
bürgerinnen und bürger brauchen jetzt
entlastung und nicht erst mit der
steuererklärung
und die mineralölkonzerne und
raffinerien die sich durch die stadt
verdienen die haben natürlich kein
problem wenn ihnen die bundesregierung
die gewinne sicher aber an die an die
trauen sie sich nicht an die profite der
konzerne steigen und der zahl der staat
zahlt das ist doch absurd meine damen
und herren besteuern sie die konzerne
und senken sie die preise durch
steuerliche zurückhaltung reden hilft
handeln ist angesagt und da machen sie
deutlich zu wenig wollen sie wirklich so
lange warten bis die preise wieder
sinken die spritpreise verschaukeln
können sich die bürgerinnen und bürger
wirklich allein meine damen und herren
die mehrheit der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer der rentnerinnen und
rentner verliert in diesen wochen in
rekordzeit an wohlstand und das ist und
bleibt habe wenn sie mir sagen das wäre
gewählt werde ich finanzierbar die
bürgerinnen und bürger schützen sie
nicht vor der preis explosion aber über
nacht erklären sie 100 milliarden ein
sondervermögen für aufrüstung der
bundeswehr das ist da warum eigentlich
100 milliarden und nicht vielleicht 87
oder 112 geht es ihnen um den bedarf
oder geht es um ihn um eine
schlagzeilenträchtige zahl ich habe das
gefühl zweiteres meine damen und herren
was sie da vorhaben ist der wahnsinn und
gegensatz zu den anderen fraktionen
dieses hauses kann ich eines sagen wir
streiten nicht darum wer der beste bei
aufrüstung ist wir finden den weg falsch
wir wollen einen anderen weg gehen und
da werden sie von der linken immer
wieder stand haben auch bei der
grundgesetzänderung meine damen und
herren ich will es mal ergänzend sagen
und aus ihren koalitionsvertrag zitieren
sie schreiben darin die ausgaben für
krisen präsentation klebt diesen
prävention humanitäre hilfe und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
sollen im maßstab eins zu eins wie die
ausgaben für verteidigung steigen auf
der grundlage des haushalts 20 21 aber
der etat wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
und entwicklung den kürzen sie sogar ihr
haushalt verstößt gegen den eigenen
koalitionsvertrag oder gibt es ein
sondervermögen humanitäre hilfe nichts
davon habe ich gehört meine damen und
herren und auch hier
auch wir als linke sagen natürlich muss
die bundeswehr ordentlich ausgestattet
werden aber wer die strukturen bei der
bundeswehr nicht grundlegend reformiert
und das management problem ab stellt der
wirt weiter milliarden verbrennen zu
spät teurer als geplant nicht
einsatzfähig so läuft doch die
beschaffung der bundeswehr bisher seit
jahren und ich weiß auch noch wer die
verteidigungsministerin und die
verteidigungsminister gestellt hat die
bundeswehr hat nicht zuerst ein geld
sondern ein strukturproblem meine damen
und herren und wenn sie das nicht lösen
werden weiter milliarden einfach
versenkt werden
und wir haben in unserer gesellschaft
eben auch das gegenstück jedes fünfte
kind in deutschland wächst in armut da
viel geld für bücher für eine jacke im
frühling für einen ausflug in den zoo
mehr als 20% armut unter kindern 20 euro
mehr gibt es jetzt für 2,9 millionen
kindern haben der reale mehrbedarf laut
sozialverbänden liegt aber bei 78 euro
das geld ist komischerweise nicht da es
ist deshalb eine politik der sozialen
kälte dass sie die kindergrundsicherung
die sie am koalitionsvertrag und was wir
gelobt haben aufgeschrieben haben bisher
0 im haushalt berücksichtigen dass im
haushalt eingestellt die kinder bleiben
haben das ein armutszeugnis für ihre
politik die gründe arbeitsprobe madonna
wird das donnerwetter haben sie die
kindergrundsicherung texten
abgeschrieben
ihr haushalt meine damen und herren ist
ein sozialpolitisches streichorchester
kindergrundsicherung kommt nicht vor
zusätzliche monate elterngeld wie sie
angekündigt haben wo ist das bürgergeld
statt hartz 4 und was ist eigentlich mit
der rente liebe hubertus heil begrüßte
auch die steigerung das ist überhaupt
keine frage aber wir wissen beide dass
das durch die inflation mehr oder
weniger aufgefressen ist im vergleich zu
2003 meine damen und herren hat sich die
zahl der rentnerinnen und rentner die
von grundsicherung also von hartz 4
leben müssen mehr als verdoppelt und
mehr als die hälfte der betroffenen sind
frauen jede dritte rentnerin und jeder
dritte rennen mit 40 jahre
versicherungsjahren muss von einer rente
und 1200 euro leben bei mir in
mecklenburg vorpommern im übrigen jeder
zweite ein komplettes arbeitsleben und
dann arbeitswege armutsrisiko das ist
und bleibt inakzeptabel das stimmt etwas
grundsätzlich nicht wieder heil deswegen
fordern mit zwei dinge sie haben vor
drei jahren vor drei jahren einen guten
ersten vorschlag zur grundrente
vorgelegt da war wirklich gut ihm hätten
wir gleich zugestimmt herausgekommen ist
aber unsere förmchen
sie haben das damit begründet dass die
union in der regierung ist okay aber ich
jetzt ist die union nicht mehr in der
regierung sie ist nicht mehr eine
regierung handeln sie jetzt stellen sie
jetzt diese grundrente noch mal hier im
bundestag vor damit wirklich etwas
passiert und zweitens heben sie das
rentenniveau auf 53 prozent an meine
damen und herren beim retten sie froh
sind wir europäische abstiegskeller das
ist die wahrheit die retten sind nicht
stabil wenn die preise explodieren
unstrittig meine damen und herren in
diesen zeiten müssen doch stärkere
schultern mehr tragen aber die einzigen
vor die sie sich verlässlich schmeißen
sind die multi millionäre und
milliardäre meine damen und herren in
der pandemie sind die superreichen in
einen einzigen goldrausch verfallen die
zehn reichsten deutschen haben ihr
vermögen um 100 milliarden vergrößert
kein geld da was für eine farce und da
rächt sich dass sich zu beginn ihrer
regierung mit einer großen steuerreform
eine absage erteilt haben was ist denn
mit den steuerversprechen
vermögenssteuer oder vermögensabgabe der
einzige sein versprechen einlöst
finanzminister linda er ist der
vermögensverwalter der superreichen
meine damen und herren das ist die
wahrheit wer bezahlt denn die 100 ein
aufrüsten
sozialdemokraten und grüne wollen im
wahlkampf da noch bei den starken
schultern bei den dicken portemonnaies
zu greifen und was ist jetzt pustekuchen
länder entscheidet nicht der kanzler wer
bezahlt denn den schuldenhaushalt 20 22
die kleinen leute bezahlen ihre
rechnungen wenn sie die steuern für die
reichen nicht anheben meine damen und
herren die schulden der bundeswehr sind
die streichungen bei sozialer sicherheit
wenn sie nicht den mut haben endlich bei
den vermögenden etwas abzugreifen und
ich sage ihnen voraus
ich sage ihnen voraus ihre ausrüstung
werden rentnerinnen und rentner
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
hartz4 empfänger mit dem berühmt
berüchtigten gürtel bezahlen den sie
noch enger schnallen sollen meine damen
und herren ihr haushalt ist wenig
zukunft und kaum zusammenhalt die
haushalt ist ein segen für die
rüstungsindustrie und eine fette
rechnung für die die tagtäglich hart
dafür arbeiten müssen dass sie ihr geld
bekommen das sie planlos und teilweise
gegen ihren eigenen koalitionsvertrag
ausgeben dass ihnen danke
das war der fraktionsvorsitzende der
linken dietmar bartsch mit heftiger
kritik an der ampel er wirft den grünen
doppelmoral vor jetzt gas von katar zu
beziehen sei keine lösung die am
friedhof zu wenig für eine eigene
unabhängige
energieversorgung überhaupt sei die
ampel völlig überfordert von einem
krisen die inflation so hoch preise für
lebensmittel gingen durch die decke mehr
entlastung für alle bürger forderten
linke und zwar sofort das 100 milliarden
paket für die bundeswehr sei zudem der
falsche weg struktur und management
seien das problem nicht fehlendes geld
nächster redner nun christian doerr
fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
überschattet die tagespolitik in einer
weise wie man sie sich nicht hätte
vorstellen können nicht vorstellen
wollen meine damen und herren die
menschen in der ukraine kämpfen ihre
freiheit und viele verlieren dabei
erleben der freiheitskampf der ukraine
er steht für die werte europas für die
werte deutschlands und für unsere
freiheit es ist la die mir putin der
fundamentale werte in frage stellt und
das auch schon über einen sehr langen
zeitraum getan hat meine damen und
herren wir müssen uns daher auch die
frage stellen wie es dazu kommen konnte
und wie wir in europa widerstandsfähiger
gegen freiheit und demokratie feinde
werden
sowohl innerhalb als auch außerhalb
unserer eigenen gesellschaft geht genau
dass dieser krieg den die russische
seite begonnen hat den wladimir putin
begonnen hat der betrifft uns alle in
europa der betrifft uns alle
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer kämpfen
auch zu unsere freiheit das dürfen wir
meine damen und herren diesen menschen
nie vergessen
und der westen europa die europäische
union die vereinigten staaten von
amerika die nato der westen steht
geschlossen und hat bereits harte
sanktionen verhängt die finanzreserven
der russischen notenbank wurden
eingefroren der rubel ist um über 40
prozent gefallen und mehr als 400
westliche firmen haben russland bereits
verlassen und den rücken gekehrt wir
wissen dass wirtschaftliche sanktionen
den krieg nicht von heute auf morgen
beenden werden leider deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir uns für
waffenlieferungen entschieden haben
meine damen und herren wir liefern
waffen in einem konfliktgebiet aufgrund
einer absoluten ausnahmesituation damit
bricht diese regierungskoalition mit
einem tabu vorheriger bundesregierung
diese entscheidung ist uns nicht leicht
gefallen ich halte diese entscheidung
für ausdrücklich richtig meine damen und
herren
und hier geht es auch um die frage
verantwortung zu übernehmen ich höre
immer wieder der bundeskanzler er merk
sagte vorhin so etwas in einem nebensatz
der bundeskanzler sei nicht laut genug
vor zwei wochen habe ich gelesen lieber
herr kollege merz dass sie als unions
vorsitzender über ein eingreifen der
nato und diesen konflikt spekuliert
haben herr merz das ist nicht nur
fahrlässig das ist verantwortungslos
hätten sie besser geschrieben hätten sie
da besser
verantwortungsvolles handeln gilt auch
in bezug auf unsere streitkräfte meine
damen und herren das ist in reden gesagt
worden wir stellen als ampelkoalition
ein sondervermögen bereit in höhe von
100 milliarden euro zur ausstattung und
zur verbesserten verteidigungs und
bündnisfähigkeit unseres landes und ich
sage dass an dieser stelle in aller
deutlichkeit weil auch das geht leider
manchmal in der tagespolitik und wir
sind es den soldatinnen und soldaten
schuldig dass wir an dieser stelle
handeln denn die stärke der bundeswehr
sie darf nicht gefährdet sein meine
damen und herren und wie alle
wir alle kennen die zahlen die
kolleginnen kollegen aus dem
verteidigungsausschuss ich habe das im
haushaltsausschuss in der vergangenen
wahlperiode gesehen wir kennen die
zahlen und wissen wo die probleme liegen
wir können keine weiteren abstriche bei
der einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr zu
lassen es geht um die
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands aber
vor allem um die frauen und männer die
bereit sind hier in deutschland ihr
leben für unsere freiheit zu riskieren
hinter unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
müssen wir jetzt insbesondere stehen in
dieser dramatischen
sicherheitspolitischen situation in
europa liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und ja herr merz hat das ja getan da ist
der rückblick auch notwendig dass teile
ich ich teile aber ausdrücklich das was
die frühere bundesverteidigungsminister
in annegret kramp-karrenbauer vor
einigen tagen gesagt hat sie sagte ich
bin so wütend auf uns weil wir
historisch versagt haben herr merz sie
hatte recht die vernachlässigung der
truppe war ein historischer fehler und
diesen historischen fehler wird dieser
regierungskoalition jetzt korrigieren
liebe kollegen und kollegen
und
musste
davon schon schmunzeln 2 eine sehr
steile these diese aufgestellt haben man
muss sich das überlegen also die
schlechte finanzierung der bundeswehr in
deutschland lag an der
regierungsbeteiligung der freien
demokraten zwischen 2009 und 2013 als
wir unter an den
bundesgesundheitsminister dem
bundesjustizminister den
bundeswirtschaftsminister
der bundesminister für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit oder den außenminister
gestellt haben natürlich lag es nicht
daran dass die union seit 2006 dem
bundesverteidigungsminister gestellt
haben und in deutschland seit 2005 dem
bundeskanzler lieben kollegen kollegen
herr merz die haben gesagt sie haben den
reden gestern gelauscht ich hätte ihnen
geraten sie hätten die letzten 16 jahre
zu hören sollen was in diesem deutschen
bundestag passiert und das wäre sinnvoll
gewesen lieber kollege
wir dürfen meine damen und herren uns in
bezug auf die auswirkungen dieses
furchtbaren angriffskrieges in europa
nichts vormachen alle bereiche des
zivilen und wirtschaftlichen lebens sind
auch bei uns von diesen krieg betroffen
wir sehen jeden tag ehrenamtliche
helferinnen und helfer an den bahnhöfen
meine damen und herren wir sehen krah
inneren und ukraine in bussen und bahnen
in unterkünften oder bei freunden und
familien zu hause meine damen und herren
und auch das will ich an dieser stelle
unterstreichen es ist daher eine ganz
zentrale aufgabe den flüchtenden
menschen zu helfen und natürlich dass
auch bundesweit gemeinsam mit ländern
und kommunen zu koordinieren ich bin
stolz auf die solidarität der menschen
in deutschland auch das muss an dieser
stelle gesagt werden herzlichen dank
dafür dass die dahinter stehen diesen
menschen zu helfen in dieser schwierigen
situation
in diesen tagen auch in bezug auf die
sanktionen wird sehr viel auch über
unsere stärke gesprochen nach was vier
wochen krieg muss man eines sagen die
geopolitische stärke des westens die
geopolitische stärke deutschlands ist
vor allem ding auch unsere
wirtschaftliche stärke wir müssen diese
sanktionen aufrecht erhalten und
verschärfen können gegebenenfalls
darüber wird jetzt ja bereits wieder
gesprochen nur dann sind wir in der lage
den menschen in der ukraine auch
wirklich zu helfen wenn wir über den
konflikt in der ukraine sprechen müssen
wir auch natürlich über die folgen hier
in deutschland sprechen meine damen und
herren wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
beschäftigten in deutschland dass die
unternehmen diese krise gut überstehen
dazu gehört auch dass wir über die see
und energiekosten sprechen müssen über
die heizkosten und über die
einkommenssituation der menschen in
unserem land wir haben uns deshalb als
ampelkoalition bereits vor einigen
wochen politisch auf den weg gemacht und
erste entscheidung hier im deutschen
bundestag in der vergangenen woche
getroffen wir verdoppeln den heizkosten
schuss für wohngeldempfänger und wir
unterstützen damit vor allen dingen
menschen mit geringen einkommen in
unserem land das ist eine frage der
sozialen gerechtigkeit das sage ich ganz
deutlich an dieser stelle
wir werden die pendlerpauschale anheben
vor allem menschen die jeden tag auf das
auto angewiesen sind um zur arbeit zu
fahren wir haben einmalzahlung für
bezieher von sozialleistungen auf den
weg gebracht und ein sofort zuschlag für
kinder aus sozial schwachen familien
eingeführt dazu kommen die anhebung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrages in noch nie
dagewesener höhe in einem einzigen
schritt und des grundfreibetrages meine
damen und herren und diese maßnahmen
weil ich die die zwischenrufe aus der
union gerade gehört hat diese maßnahmen
werden wir sogar steuerlich rückwirkend
zum ersten januar diesen jahres
einführen um das auch nochmals
unterstreichen liebe kollegen kollegen
und dann machen wir das meine damen und
herren
doch darauf kann man auch ein stück weit
stolzen und dann machen wir das was die
union jahrelang nicht geschafft hat was
sie jahrelang in ihren wahlprogrammen
gesteht stadt stehen lassen was sie
jahrelang immer wieder aufgerufen hat
aber am ende nicht wirklich durchgesetzt
hat wir werden die menschen insbesondere
bei den stromkosten entlassen diese
bundesregierung aus sozialdemokraten
grünen und freien demokraten
sie wird die eeg-umlage für alle
menschen für alle unternehmen in
deutschland vollständig und für immer
abschaffen und das bereits zum ersten
juli dieses jahres das ist ein verdienst
dieser seite des hauses über das sie den
letzten jahren nur gesprochen haben
liebe kollegen der union
dass die energiekosten bei vielen
unternehmen bis zu mittlerweile 30
prozent und darüber tragen das ist
leider keine seltenheit mehr deshalb
haben wir uns für die genannten
entlastungsschritte entschieden
gleichzeitig müssen wir strategisch
unabhängiger werden insbesondere vom
russischen erdgas meine damen und herren
und deshalb begrüße ich die anstrengung
auch die aktuellen des
bundeswirtschaftsministers auch andere
erdgasquellen jetzt zu erschließen das
ist richtig und entsprechend ist es auch
wichtig in deutschland etwas zu tun und
dabei denke ich natürlich an die lng
terminals die beispielsweise der
bundeskanzler bei seiner
regierungserklärung bereits erwähnt hat
die standorte in wilhelmshaven in
brunsbüttel und als niedersachse darf
ich sagen natürlich auch in stade denn
eins ist doch ganz klar
danke kollege klingen bei den einst ist
doch auch ganz klar deutschland wird
auch zukünftig auf energieimporte
angewiesen seien und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt die richtigen infrastruktur
entscheidung treffen meine damen und
herren an dieser stelle muss man eines
sagen diese koalition hat eine doppelte
hypothek geerntet nein nicht geerntet
der entschuldigung eine doppelte
hypothek geerbt auf der einen seite eine
viel zu starke abhängigkeit russlands
bei energieimporten und auf der anderen
seite und deswegen haben wir bereits
entlastet bei energie auf der anderen
seite historische bereits vor der
ukraine krise historische belastung der
deutschen stromkunden der deutschen
kunden für gast et cetera pp das waren
zwei große hypotheken die wir jetzt
bereinigen wollen meine damen und herren
unsere botschaft lautet wir lassen
unsere unternehmen und die menschen in
deutschland bei der frage der
energieversorgung nicht im regen stehen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese die arbeit dieser koalition ist
belangt bislang bestimmt insbesondere
durch krisen und durch die folgen daraus
doch wir machen uns natürlich auch
gedanken um die zukunft wie wir
fortschritt organisieren wie wir mehr
fortschritt wagen meine damen und herren
nicht nur die krisenbewältigung ist
unsere agenda sondern wir richten den
blick nach vorne und ich will ein punkt
ansprechen der in den letzten jahren in
deutschland zu kurz gekommen ist und
mein persönlicher eindruck ist es lag
nicht an den koalitionspartner spd in
den vergangenen jahren ich glaube es ist
jetzt die aufgabe der deutschen politik
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund der
unsicherheit in der welt diese
bundesregierung wird das
aufstiegsversprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft erneuern meine damen und
herren das ist jetzt eine ganz
entscheidende frage auch für die
zukunftsfähigkeit unseres landes
wir werden uns um gründerinnen und
gründer kümmern wir werden dafür sorgen
die planungszeiten in deutschland zu
halbieren in deutschland gibt es 83
millionen kluge köpfe die lust haben
durchzustarten die lust haben was mit
ihrem leben zu machen die lust haben
sich zu engagieren
ob ehrenamtlich oder im beruf meine
damen und herren diese art der freier
die ich damit meine das eigene leben zu
gestalten daraus etwas zu machen und ja
auch daraus wirtschaftlichen erfolg zu
ernten meine damen und herren dieses
zentrale aufstiegsversprechen der
sozialen marktwirtschaft muss jetzt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert endlich
erneuert werden nach so vielen jahren
des mythos liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden das wir werden das
ja sehr konkret tun wir werden das tun
indem wir beispielsweise 4000 talent
schulen gründen meine damen und herren
wir werden das und dass es mir ein
herzensanliegen gerade als ehemaliger
landespolitiker wir werden das machen
indem wir einen digital pack 2.0 endlich
auf den weg bringen meine damen und
herren meine fraktion hat in der
vergangenen periode der unionsgeführten
bundesregierung zu einer
grundgesetzänderung mehrheit geholfen
damit ein digital park endlich bei den
schulen ankommen und über jahre ist
nichts passiert ich erinnere mich sehr
genau an die reden der ehemaligen
bundesbildungsministerin an dieser
stelle die schulter zuckend da stand und
man hatte den eindruck sie ist
abteilungsleiterinnen an schlecht
geführten baumarkt nach dem motto das
ist nicht meine abteilung nein das ist
unsere abteilung der digital packte
schulen die chancen fähigkeit die frage
eben auch des sozialen aufstiegs durch
bessere bildung das werden wir jetzt
gewährleisten auch das ist eine frage
der sozialen gerechtigkeit die
bildungsfrage ist eine solche frage in
unserem land und dafür bin ich verdiene
schlagbar ausdrücklich dankbar die das
zur chefsache gemacht
als koalition wollen wir in den
kommenden wochen deutlich machen dass
wir trotz der panne bekämpfen trotz
diesen buchbaren dieses natürlich
zusätzliche mittel bereitstellen für die
wichtigen zukunftsaufgaben einerseits
natürlich bei der transformation auf
unserer volkswirtschaft hin zu mehr
klima- und neutralität richtig ist eben
und das will ich sagen zum schluss
richtig ist dass wahrscheinlich kaum
eine bundesregierung in der geschichte
der bundesregierung bundesrepublik
deutschland wahrscheinlich gar keine
neue bundesregierung unter solchen
rahmenbedingungen
gestartet ist eine pandemie ein krieg in
europa der zusätzlich zu all dem
schrecklichen leid der menschen in der
ukraine auch noch unsere eigene
sicherheit hier in deutschland bedroht
meine damen und herren und gleichzeitig
gigantische zukunftsaufgaben bei der
digitalisierung bei der dekarbonisierung
unseres landes und das als letzten punkt
natürlich auch bei der demographischen
frage die aus meiner sicht eine
entscheidende soziale frage in den
kommenden jahren sein wird die wahrheit
ist meine damen und herren deutschland
ist eines der ältesten länder der welt
der vater ist 81 jahre alt und sehr
gesund und ich freue mich darüber dass
menschen in deutschland gesund älter
werden das ist ein großer
zivilisatorischer fortschritt und
gleichzeitig ist eine gigantische
herausforderung wir sehen das an den
zahlen an den zuschüssen im
bundeshaushalt von christian lindner in
die gesetzliche versicherung meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die frage der
demographie ist eine frage der so des
sozialen zusammenhalts in deutschland in
den kommenden jahren und wir werden das
nicht allein aus eigener bevölkerung
schaffen meine damen und herren und
deswegen ist ein punkt zum schluss
richtig weil ich vorne auch über die
solidarität und offenheit gegenüber
geflüchteten menschen aus der ukraine
sprach gleichzeitig und davon auch los
wirst in die zukunft gedacht müssen wir
auch eine andere historische aufgabe
herr merz als ampel koalition lösen zu
der die union in den letzten 16 jahren
nicht der nicht in der lage war wir
müssen aus deutschland endlich ein
modernes einwanderungsland machen meine
damen und herren wir sind es unseren
wohlstand schuldig ein weltoffenes
einwanderungsland was unseren vorstand
in zukunft sicher und gleichzeitig die
globalisierung voranbringt und unseren
platz auch inmitten dieser weltoffenen
länder sichern liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich bin dem bundeskanzler dankbar für
die rede heute morgen und ich bin der
bundesfinanzminister sehr dankbar für
einen soliden haushalt und das als
letzten satz zur präsidentin bei der
frage der schuldenbremse ja man kann
unterschiedlicher meinung in der
haushaltspolitik sein aber bei der frage
der schuldenbremse darin sich an
verträge zu halten da traue ich olaf
scholz und dieser ampel koalition um
meilen weit mehr als dieser
oppositionsfraktion ganz herzlichen dank
diese kollegen gelegt
auch in der rede des
fraktionsvorsitzenden der fdp christian
doerr ging es natürlich um die
bundeswehr die vernachlässigung sei ein
historischer fehler der union aber das
würde die ampel jetzt korrigieren auch
die bürger zu entlasten vor allem bei
den energiekosten das werde die ampel
jetzt machen betonte dr es folgt nun
mathias middelberg er ist
innenpolitischer sprecher der
unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
kollegen
der bundeskanzler sie haben hier heute
in einem fast erschöpfenden beitrag
ihre eigene regierung gelobt
unter erwähnung der einzelnen minister
kollegen und kolleginnen und herr dürr
hat eben schon die regierungspolitik
gelobt die noch gar nicht stattgefunden
hat mit allen möglichen ankündigung
das
beeindruckt vielleicht den einen oder
anderen in ihren eigenen reihen aber
wenn man jetzt mal ganz nüchtern bilanz
zieht über die letzten 100 tage und sich
ein paar projekte sehr konkret anguckt
dann kommt man glaube ich zur nüchternen
einschätzung
der bundeskanzler hat hier angekündigt
eine impfpflicht würde eingeführt ende
februar anfang märz der bundeskanzler
immerhin chef der regierung mit der
leitung der regierungsgeschäfte nach der
verfassung beauftragt also das ist schon
eine wertige aussage gehandelt gehandelt
hat die regierung zu diesem thema nicht
jedenfalls haben wir kein handeln der
regierung dazu festgestellt
infektionsschutzgesetz
da feiern sie sich auch für das was sie
gemacht haben tatsächlich haben sie uns
bei der debatte in der letzten woche zum
infektionsschutzgesetz das maximum an
meinungsdifferenzen ihrer koalition
vorgeführt und haben damit gezeigt diese
regierung ist gar nicht handlungsfähig
sie haben das problem an die länder
delegiert weil sie selbst nicht lösungs
fähig sind thema energiepreise herr dürr
sie haben eben gesagt sie freuen sich
darüber dass jetzt in der koalition
darüber gesprochen wird
gesprochen wird das ist natürlich für
die menschen die jetzt in diesen monaten
bangen ob sie überhaupt noch finanziell
klar kommen ob sie ihre tankrechnung
noch bezahlen können die 23 400 euro
mehr als pendler bezahlen müssen die als
busunternehmer um ihre existenz bangen
oder als gewerbetreibender dass es für
die sicherlich eine wichtige information
dass sie über das thema in der koalition
sprechen
besser wär's wenn sie dieses problem
jetzt entschieden angehen würden wir
haben dazu klare vorschläge unterbreitet
die sind sehr einfach umsetzbar wenn sie
das machen würden können wir das in
dieser woche im bundestag noch
beschließen und der bundesrat kann das
dann zeitnah absegnen und dann sind die
dinge unmittelbar an der tankstelle
wirksam
thema
thema zeitenwende das hat friedrich merz
völlig zurecht angesprochen und wir
haben ja hier die verschiedenen
konsequenzen auf den furchtbaren krieg
in der ukraine diskutiert und wir haben
auch über das sondervermögen diskutiert
und da glaube ich ist es schon so wie
friedrich merz dass auch festgestellt
hat
irgendwie glaube ich müssen wir das auch
geistig noch nachvollziehen was jetzt
stattfinden muss und vor allen dingen
sie in diesem teil des hauses müssen
dass geistig wirklich verarbeiten ja ich
sage das ganz deutlich ich kann mich
sehr genau an den letzten
bundestagswahlkampf erinnern und da
wurde häufig auch die
verteidigungspolitik die
verteidigungsausgaben die ausgaben für
die bundeswehr diskutiert und dann wurde
in manchen veranstaltungen gefragt wer
ist denn für die einhaltung des zwei
prozent ziels der nato da habe ich die
hand gehoben bei den veranstaltungen und
auch der kollege der fdp der damals
kandidiert hatte die kollegen die
kandidiert haben aus den anderen
parteien haben jeweils gesagt nee das
kommt nicht in frage das ist ein blödes
ziel das wollen wir nicht machen die
bundeswehr ist für uns nachrangig wir
haben ja kaum noch relevante
verteidigungs aufträge sondern verein
setzte international und das jetzt
einmal verstanden zu haben was ist denn
jetzt die lehre die quintessenz aus
diesem krieg was ist denn die botschaft
aus diesem unglaublichen tabubruch dass
wir tatsächlich in dem ein oder anderen
punkt umdenken müssen dieses land europa
ist wieder bedroht und wir müssen uns
auch wieder auf ein szenario der
landesverteidigung einstellen und
deswegen müssen wir in dem bereich
nacharbeiten die fdp hat dabei wenig
nachzuarbeiten
aber dieser teil der regierung hat das
wirklich geistig zu verarbeiten und
darstellen wir hier nicht fest wenn wir
über die verwendung der hunde
und dann erklärt uns der kollege kinder
kindler aus der grünen fraktion gestern
da ging es auch um zivile
krisenprävention
irgendwo in teilen der welt dann kann
ich nur sagen das zeigt ganz deutlich
dass die botschaft nicht verstanden
wurde denn der ukraine krieg zeigt uns
dass die massnahmen zivile
krisenprävention
alle maßnahmen der diplomatie hier
leider leider gescheitert sind und
deswegen müssen wir zurück zu einem
klaren szenario der absoluten
verteidigungsbereitschaft und
verteidigungsfähigkeit und deswegen ist
unser punkt der das wir sagen die 100
milliarden müssen der bundeswehr und
ihrer ausstattung zur verfügung stehen
ich will an dem punkt ich will an dem
punkt noch mal nach halten ich fand das
sehr bemerkenswert was vor drei wochen
der kollege habeck der jetzt leider
gerade nicht mehr unter uns ist
kann ihnen wir der eine oder andere dann
erzählen aber zum thema ja super zum
thema waffenlieferungen gesagt hat ich
fand das sehr bemerkenswert da habe ich
sage das ausdrücklich und anerkennt was
sie zum thema waffenlieferung in der
debatte vor drei wochen die wir hier an
dem sonntag hatten gesagt haben wie sich
auch selber ich sag das mal ein bisschen
damit gequält haben und ihre eigene
fraktion dazu angesprochen haben die
sich nämlich auch mit dem thema quält
und ich habe da durchaus verständnis für
aber das zeigt ja gerade dass man diese
situation diese zeitenwende von der der
bundeskanzler zu recht gesprochen hat
dass wir nie wirklich auch geistig
innerlich verarbeiten und darauf
ernsthaft reagieren und das nicht mit
einem lippenbekenntnis getan ist dass
man sagt so jetzt machen wir mal diese
100 milliarden und dann ist die sache
für uns gegessen und die auch noch neben
der schuldenbremse nein wir müssen das
wirklich verstehen und deswegen ist für
uns auch essenziell die forderung dass
wir wenn das wenn die 100 milliarden
sondervermögen auslaufen dass wir danach
daran festhalten müssen dass die
bundeswehr absolut verteidigungsbereich
bleiben muss das muss auch in zukunft so
gelten und deswegen sagen wir gerade die
zwei prozent müssen eingehalten werden
auch über dieses datum des auslaufens
des sondervermögens hinaus
ich hätte jetzt gerne noch einiges zu
ihrem haushalt gesagt da haben sie glück
dass ihnen das jetzt erspart wird mal
meine redezeit leider für den anderen
punkt und die anderen punkte
aufgebraucht ist aber die bemerkung herr
dürr will ich mir dann doch noch
erlauben sie haben sich eben bei herrn
lindner dafür bedankt dass er einen
soliden haushalt vorlegen würde ich sage
ihnen ganz ehrlich das was vorliegt kann
allenfalls eine vorläufige überschlägige
betrachtung dessen sein mit dem wir noch
irgendwie rechnen müssen denn
ehrlicherweise diskutieren wir in dieser
woche über vier bundeshaushalte den
kernhaushalt mit 100 milliarden
neuverschuldung das sondervermögen mit
100 milliarden neuverschuldung dann
diskutieren wir über einen ergänzungs
haushalt ukraine oder gar nicht wissen
wie viel milliarden dar eingebucht
werden sollen und dann diskutieren wir
ehrlicherweise noch über die 60
milliarden die sie ja mal eben so rüber
getragen haben von daher vom alten jahr
und der alten regierung jetzt in ihre
zeit das waren kreditermächtigung die
hätten verfallen müssen weil wir sie für
corona gar nicht in anspruch genommen
haben wie haben sie mitgenommen um sie
jetzt für ganz andere zwecke nämlich als
klima mittel einzusetzen das ist die
ehrliche betrachtung also davon solide
zu sprechen sage ich mal ist mindestens
mal höchst ambitioniert er nicht der
fall
mathias middelberg von der cdu wirft der
ampel vor nicht handlungsfähig zu sein
das zeige sich zum beispiel beim thema
verteilung der flüchtlinge die
vielzitierte zeitenwende müsse besser
durchdacht werden dass zwei prozent ziel
langfristig verankert werden fordert
mittelberg nun folgt rolf mützenich
fraktionsvorsitzender der spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
haushaltspolitische debatten werden in
der regel von themen der wirtschaft
sozialklima und innenpolitik dominiert
doch die ukraine die welt und unsere
bisherigen regeln wurden in den
morgenstunden des 24
februar angegriffen
light flucht seit mehr als vier jahren
nicht mehr als vier wochen verstört und
die brutalität mit der putin ein staat
ein echter will wir sehen aus der gar
nicht so ferne großen ferne bilder der
unmenschlichkeit die wir in europa nicht
mehr für möglich gehalten haben und wir
sehen bei uns besonders aber in polen
ungarn oder moldawien die millionen von
frauen kindern und älteren menschen
fliehen müssen sie alle werden einer
friedlichen heimat braut dennoch dachte
er kriegt die agenda in der wir der welt
von gestern eine neue zukunft gegenüber
stellen wollen nicht aufheben im
gegenteil gerade jetzt sind wir
gefordert antworten zu geben wie wir
nach dem zweiten bruch des krieges die
herausforderung für unser land für
europa und den planeten meistern können
der krieg meine damen und herren
der kriegt meine damen und herren hat
vieles verändert zusammen mit den
anderen ländern unterstützen wir ein
beispielloses sanktionsregime das und
wir müssen es sagen auch uns nicht
unbeschadet zurück lassen wird die
folgen werden jahre nachwirken wir haben
der ukraine im einklang mit der charta
der vereinten nationen waffen zur
selbstverteidigung
geliefert und leisten wie kein anderes
land wirtschaftliche und humanitäre
hilfe wo wir können werden wir diese
hilfe auch weiterhin leisten unsere
fraktion meine fraktion wird das
verantwortungsvoll und gewissenhaft
zusammen mit der mehrheit dieses hauses
tun darauf meine damen und herren können
sie sich verlassen
gegenwärtig wachsen die kommunen und die
zivilgesellschaft über sich hinaus
engagierte bürgerinnen und bürger nehmen
frauen kinder und familien mit großer
wärme in empfang
organisieren kurzfristig eine bleibe
medizinische hilfe und die teilnahme am
schulunterricht für die kinder in
momenten wie diesen meine damen und
herren wird uns gewahr dass unsere
demokratische und bürgerschaftliche
verfasstheit von unschätzbarem wert ist
für ein friedliches
gern friedliches miteinander und den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und für
diese gelebte solidarität möchte ich
mich bei den vielen vielen menschen in
deutschland bedanken vielen dank dafür
auch
meine damen und herren in den
organisationen der staatengemeinschaft
tut sich weg weisen dass die europäische
union hat zu neuer geschlossenheit
gefunden morgen besucht der
amerikanische präsident die europäische
union und die nato das in washington mit
joe biden ein staatsoberhaupt amtiert
dass die zusammenarbeit mit europa wie
kein zweiter verkörpert ist ein
glücksfall was für eine erleichterung
gegenüber den erlebten viele kolleginnen
und kollegen
und ich finde nicht vergessen dürfen wir
den europarat in straßburg und die
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa in wien beide
institutionen haben ihre eigenen stärken
und müssen eine wichtige rolle in der
nachkriegszeit einnehmen zumal die
anstrengungen durch entsandte aus vielen
parlamenten in der osze und im europarat
ergänzt werden können gemeinschaftliches
handeln liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das zeigt sich in diesen wochen ist ein
wert an sich und genau das brauchen wir
in diesen tagen
eben so
das wird aus meiner sicht vergessen
schafft das völkerrecht klarheit und
überzeugungskraft wir begrüßen
ausdrücklich dass der chef ankläger am
internationalen strafgerichtshof ein
ermittlungsverfahren zu kriegsverbrechen
völkermord und verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit eröffnet hat nach unserem
verständnis
nach unserem verständnis müssen sich die
ermittlungen aber außerdem auf den
vorwurf des angriffskrieges beziehen das
sind wir den opfern und das sind wir der
ukraine schuldig die möglichkeit
verantwortliche persönlich zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen darf nicht
ungenutzt bleiben darauf bestehen wir
meine damen und herren
nachdem auch der internationale
gerichtshof vergangenen mittwoch
angeordnet hat dass russland die
militärische gewalt in der ukraine
sofort beenden muss kann sich niemand
mehr in moskau hinter fadenscheinigen
juristischen argumenten oder
abwegigen vergleichen versteckten die
richterinnen und richter in den haag am
völkerrechtliche klarheit geschaffen das
ist ein fortschritt im internationalen
recht und genau das ist gut auch für
dieses parlament weil wir stehen hinter
dem internationalen recht und haben es
auf den weg gebracht meine damen und
herren
und selbst in new york es nicht alles
beim alten geblieben zwar hat sich der
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
erneut als unfähig erwiesen seinem
auftrag zur wahrung des internationalen
friedens nachzukommen russland legte
erwartungsgemäß ein veto ein aber auch
die volksrepublik china
enthielt sich der stimme
solange peking und da sage ich hier ganz
klar aus dem manifesten bruch des
völkerrechts keine konsequenzen für das
eigene handeln zieht bleibt die
volksrepublik china hinter den selbst
geweckten erwartungen zurück wir sagen
klar lösen sie sich aus der schlinge
eines kriegsverbrechens solange das noch
möglich ist stellen sie sich auf die
seite der menschlichkeit und des
friedens
aber auch die länder wie die vereinigten
arabischen emiraten haben das privileg
ihres nicht ständigen sitz im
sicherheitsrat nicht ausgefüllt leider
wollte abu dhabi den überfall auf die
ukraine nicht verurteilen
es war daher richtig dass der
wirtschaftsminister
dieses dank dieses verhalten bei seinem
besuch angesprochen hat dafür möchte ich
mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen bedanken
anders als der sicherheitsrat hat die
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen eine klare entscheidung
getroffen
141 von 193 staaten
verurteilten die aggressions russlands
nur fünf stimmten mit nein 35
regierungen enthielten sich der stimme
und zwölf repräsentanten waren in new
york nicht anwesend auf den ersten blick
ist das ein klares votum doch wir
sollten genauer hinschauen zumal wir
europäer die größte zahl der staaten die
die militärische aggression russlands
nicht verurteilt haben befinden sich auf
dem eurasischen kontinent oder in afrika
also unmittelbar in unserer nähe oder in
nicht ganz weiter ferne und deswegen
würde ich ihnen gerne diese karte die
vielleicht die neue weltordnung
zumindestens im entstehen ist
zumindestens vor augen führen weil wir
sollten uns das vergegenwärtigen was das
bedeutet im verhältnis zur
weltbevölkerung ist dass die hälfte der
menschheit darunter befinden sich viele
autoritär regierte staaten aber auch
demokratien wie indien oder
unvollständige demokratien wie südafrika
oder sri lanka
fünf staaten welche sich der
verurteilung russlands auf dieser karte
nicht anschließen wollten sind außer den
atomwaffen möchte und ich finde es lohnt
sich in einer solchen debatte den blick
auf vielleicht eine weltordnung zugeht
so zu lenken die im entstehen begriffen
ist weil sie ist nicht schwarz oder weiß
wie uns immer einige einreden wollen und
auf diese im entstehen begriffene
weltordnung wird es keine einfachen
antworten geben schon gar nicht allein
militärische und das sollten hoffentlich
den meisten auch in diesem haus klar
sein dass wir die ausrüstung und das
sage ich gleichzeitig mit dazu dass wir
die ausrüstung der soldatinnen und
soldaten verbessern bleibt dennoch
richtig genauso wie die anschaffung von
neuen geräten
meine fraktion wird dabei gleichzeitig
darauf achten und hinwirken dass der
bundestag bei der verausgabung der
mittel ein entscheidendes wort mitreden
wird ohne parlaments kontrolle meine
damen und herren gibt es keine
demokratische sicherheitspolitik und die
bundeswehr muss eine parlaments an die
leiden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die spd ist nach wie vor der auffassung
dass zur kriegs verhinderung mehr gehört
als immer größer rüstungsausgaben und
schon gar nicht gehört dazu
nachfolgenden generationen
vorzuschreiben wie hoch diese zu sein
haben wie die union ist will denn einige
zudem einen zur bündnisverteidigung
gehöre ein weltweites militärisches
engagement unserer streitkräfte dazu zu
sagen wie auch dem das ist nicht unser
verständnis einer klugen außen und
sicherheitspolitik denn wir haben
nämlich noch ja genau das nicht das aha
in ihrer fraktion sondern sie hätten
sich in den letzten jahren 16 jahren
dazu durchringen können nämlich wir
haben noch vieles und anderes zu tun
bevor wir allein kuriose investitionen
tätigen und immer wieder neue ziele
formulieren so wie sie das hier tun
sollten wir zuerst klären was die
bundeswehr leisten kann aber auch
leisten soll alle sind 1000 einmal wird
ja ich hatte johann gehalten knacken sie
eine frage oder bemerkung der kollegin
zu erinnern ja ich wollte das nicht sie
hat sie schon seit zehn minuten gemeldet
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob sich sowohl
einfach keine luft fitte
ja sehr geehrter kollege mützenich
vielen herzlichen dank dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen mir geht es
darum dass ihr als chef der stärksten
fraktion im deutschen bundestag würde
ich sie einfach persönlich fragen wollen
wir haben situationen alle kümmern sich
im moment in unserem land dankenswerter
weise um die ankommenden flüchtlinge und
auch meiner region sind beispielsweise
aus der region riefen flüchtlinge
angekommen das sind wird er mit kindern
die große sorge haben um ihre männer die
dort an der grenze zu weißrussland
wahrscheinlich massiv unter druck
geraten könnten denn dort besteht die
gefahr dass weißrussland eine
unrühmliche rolle einnimmt und deswegen
die konkrete frage als sie was
unternehmen sie als chef der stärksten
fraktion im deutschen bundestag um dort
die zivilisten männer die bürger wären
dort zumindest so weit gehend zu
schützen dass sie brustpanzer zur
verfügung haben dass sie hell mit zur
verfügung haben denn nach jetzigem
kenntnisstand stehen sie sozusagen mit
bloßen händen dort und haben eben die
berechtigte sorge dass sie dort in einen
weiteren konflikt in eine weitere
auseinandersetzung mit hineingezogen
werden gibt es schon abmachungen mit
unternehmen die brustpanzer produzieren
sie wissen wie es im moment im aktuellen
weltgeschehen
die diesbezüglich aussieht aber am ende
des tages sind des zivilisten sind
menschen die in der bürgerwehr sich
organisiert haben was unternehmen sie
konkret um dies den menschen zu helfen
losgelöst von den waffen die ja auch zur
debatte stehen aber das ist ja noch mal
eine andere hausnummer dingen was
unternehmen sie konkret
[Applaus]
kollegin 72
gingen hier in ihrer zwischen
intervention in ihrer frage angesprochen
das eine ist dass viele frauen mit ihren
kindern aber auch ältere menschen nach
deutschland kommen und ich habe eben und
ich hoffe für das ganze haus auch gesagt
vielen dank an die die ein
bürgerschaftliches engagement die eine
bleibe diesen menschen geben und ich
denke das werden sie auch ihnen gesagt
haben dass sie willkommen sind und dass
wir alles dafür tun dass in dieser zeit
in der sie bei uns sind humanität der
erste sozusagen das erste angebot an sie
ist und was darauf weiteres folgt und da
will ich auch an die kolleginnen und
kollegen der cdu csu fraktion erinnern
dass die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
eben auch mit unionsgeführten
bundesländer eben genau diese
willkommenskultur
entschieden hat auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber
gleichzeitig auch gesagt hat wir wollen
gemeinsam mit dem bund mit den ländern
und mit den kommunen uns auf den weg
machen letztlich auch die finanziellen
lasten gemeinsam zu teilen das ist meine
einladung an sie helfen sie uns dabei
dass in dieser arbeitsgruppe gutes auf
den weg gebracht wird und das zweite
um das zweite betrifft die
waffenlieferungen
in der tat diese bundesregierung
zusammen mit dem parlament hat eine
schwerwiegende entscheidung getroffen
und ich habe es ganz bewusst manchmal
über hört man das doch hier dies auch
vor dem hintergrund
des internationalen rechts gesagt der
charta der vereinten nationen auf der
grundlage der charta der vereinten
nationen dass sich nämlich länder selbst
verteidigen können sind auch wir bereit
gewesen an die ukraine waffen zu liefern
zur selbstverteidigung und ich finde das
ist nicht nur beachtenswert sondern das
ist ein solidarbeitrag den wir innerhalb
des bündnisses innerhalb der
europäischen union aber auch als
souveränes land gegeben haben und ich
finde das können sie den menschen die
sie angesprochen haben auch durchaus
sagen das ist ein wichtiger schritt und
wir werden weiterhin auch diese hilfe
leisten meine damen und herren aber und
das sagen wir auch ganz klar sie können
sich ihrer verantwortung nicht entziehen
indem sie hier an die bundeswehr
bestimmte erwartungen äußern ohne aber
uns dabei zu helfen auch andere fragen
mit zu beantworten ja wir wollen große
investitionen tätigen
aber wir wollen eben auch zuerst klären
was diese bundeswehr leisten kann und
was sie leisten soll alles auf einmal
das habe ich gesagt wird dich gehen
zumal die erfahrungen der beschaffung
kollege merz einschließlich der
sonderwünsche einen realitätstest
unterzogen werden müssen warum wir in
europa jährlich mit 200 milliarden euro
verteidigungsausgaben nicht wehrhafter
sein können erschließt sich mir nicht
auch das ist eine große aufgabe
innerhalb der europäischen union
aber auch das militär wird bis der nagel
und nicht finde zu einer ernsthaften
debatte im deutschen bundestag
gehört genauso mit dazu wir über die
frage der waffenlieferungen zu sprechen
dass wir als stärkste wirtschaftsmacht
in europa zudem lernen müssen lernen
müssen das ist ein langer weg mit den
größten rüstungsetat in europa
verantwortungsvoll umzugehen ohne
humanitäre hilfe wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und abrüstung zu
vernachlässigen wir wollen diese
bereiche genau so gestärkt wir sehen wie
die investition in die bundeswehr meine
gang
und deswegen sage ich auch ganz klar
unsere überzeugung resultieren nicht aus
weltfremden idealismus oder wir uns
immer vorgeworfen wird aus reiner
naivität sie stützen sich auf erfahrung
einer politik die den kalten krieg
maßgeblich mit überwunden hat darauf
werden wir sozialdemokraten immer stolz
zurückblicken und die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen daraus für unser
konkretes heutiges handeln ziehen beide
sich möglich meine damen und herren
genau diesen weg wird meine fraktion
auch in den nächsten jahren gehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
pandemien
klimawandel und der krieg in der ukraine
fordern uns alle heraus der
finanzminister hat recht als
solidargemeinschaft müssen wir
zusammenstehen darin ihr kollege lindner
stimmen wir überein und wenn wir dann
noch übereinkommen dass in gefährlichen
zeiten starke schultern der
solidargemeinschaft zusätzlichen halt
geben müssen tun wir das lieber kollege
lindner auch sehr gerne diese
unterstützung werden sie
zum schluss möchte ich auch den moment
zurück kommen als wir in einer neuen
koalition zusammengefunden haben wir
sind gemeinsam der überzeugung innere
reform die soziale kraft und die
sicherung der freiheit sind die besten
antworten auf autoritäre
herausforderungen im innern wie ihm
äußern nur so bleiben wir attraktiv als
demokratische gemeinschaft und
konkurrenzfähig als moderne sozial und
wirtschaftsnationen kurzum wir müssen
politisch wirtschaftlich und
technologisch vorangehen darin liegt die
große stärke unseres landes und seiner
menschen und die bundesregierung und die
sie tragenden parteien werden alles
dafür tun dass das in den nächsten vier
jahren möglich wird liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und deswegen
wollen wir gute arbeit durch eine kluge
ökonomische und ökologische
transformation sicherstellen und neue
arbeit schaffen wir wollen an die
erfolgreiche tradition einer
kooperativen sozialpolitik anknüpfen und
zusammen mit arbeitgebern gewerkschaften
und den bundesländern unser
wirtschaftsmodell stärken das ist unser
bild von der zukunft und wir werden es
verwirklichen meine damen und herren
nämlich weil wir ein starkes land sind
und mit verstand gewirtschaftet haben
können wir die herausforderungen
meistern wir brauchen soziale sicherheit
im innern gerade dann wenn die äußere
sicherheit bedroht ist dazu gehört
auch die anhebung des mindestlohns
genauso wie das grundrecht auf wohnen zu
erschwinglichen preisen
die pandemie hat uns zudem gelehrt warum
wir ein gesundheitssystem brauchen dass
solidarität gute beschäftigung und
vorsorge zusammen denkt wir haben
versprochen dass wir deutschland
moderner ökologischer und gerechter
machen wollen deshalb unterstützt meine
fraktion den etatentwurf der neuen
bundesregierung und wird gleichzeitig
weitere verbesserungen vorschlagen mit
dem haushalt haben wir die
herausforderungen der zeitenwende
angenommen damit schaffen wir ein
fundament für die zukunft und ich finde
diesen weg wollen und können wir
gemeinsam gehen vielen danke jungs nach
sagt
rolf mützenich lobte die derzeit gelebte
solidarität in deutschland in der innen-
und in der ampel gemeinschaftliches
handeln sei jetzt das gebot der stunde
deutliche worte richtete er an china
sich endlich auf die richtige seite zu
stellen kürze nicht warnte von neuen
allianzen fünf staaten hätten sich der
verurteilung russlands nicht
angeschlossen das müsse ein alarmzeichen
für alle demokratien zu sein nächster
redner ist nun alexander gauland von der
afd
[Applaus]
präsidentin meine damen und herren
selten noch ist eine ins neue sub
gekommene regierung so schnell und so
gründlich auf den boden der tatsachen
angekommen
wenn es nicht um deutschland um uns alle
ginge könnte man fast schadenfreude
finden aber das ist hier nicht mein ziel
da bittet ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
dessen ziel das ende der fossilen
energiewirtschaft ist arabischen
scheichs um flüssiggas
und eine außenministerin die von
feministischer außenpolitik träumt muss
sich eine neue sicherheitsarchitektur
ausdenken und allem steht ein
regierungschef vor dessen partei noch
kürzlich
bewaffnete drohnen für unvereinbar mit
den deutschen friedens willen wird wir
haben eine damen und herren in puncto
sicherheit hat die regierung schnell
gelernt
und 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
sind schon ein erstaunlicher lernerfolg
für politiker die im festen glauben an
eine regelbasierte
multilaterale außenpolitik groß geworden
sind
doch meine damen und herren wie immer in
fällen von über kompensationen droht
jetzt die übertragung
ich weiß es ist schwer im angesicht von
ruinen
einem angriffskrieg und millionen
flüchtlinge die eigenen fehler also die
fehler des westens in der vergangenheit
zu benennen nur so viel
man soll niemals einer großmacht eine
großmacht demütigen
bismarck hat darin 1870 71 gewirkt die
sieger des ersten weltkrieges
1919 in wasser
und der westen meine damen und herren
leider nach
1989 denn was wir getan haben war eine
demütigung russlands wir haben eine
weltordnung versucht aufzubauen ohne auf
diese großmacht rücksicht zu nehmen und
das meine damen und herren heißt
dass trotz allem was geschehen ist
dort dieses angriffskrieges eine
europäische friedensordnung nur mit
russland aber niemals gegen das größte
land europas möglich ist
es ist der turm des russischen
präsidenten zu glauben
größe käme allein aus den gewehrläufen
oder heute aus der atomraketen
größe und stärke eines landes beruhen zu
meisten auf der akzeptanz des staates
nach innen wie nach außen
und das ist das defizit des russischen
präsidenten
die großen zahlen auf die er sich gerne
beruft waren reformer
alexander der erste
der bezwinger napoleons und
alexander dort zweiter der baum befreit
was sollten was können wir tun um
russland auf diesen europäischen weg
zurückzuführen
meine damen und herren wir können
eintreten als ehrlicher makler
für eine neutrale
das wäre die zukunft
meine damen und herren damit ich nicht
verstanden werde
neutralität heißt nicht
neutralität der gedanken und herzen
aber neutralität der tagen
sanktionen die das russische volk
treffen sind falsch wie die lieferung
von angriffswaffen die nichts besser
aber vieles noch schlimmer machen oder
gar kriegshandlung wie die sperrung des
luftraums über der ukraine
und ich bin dem bundeskanzler dankbar
dass er ganz klar gesagt hat dass wir
nicht teil dieses krieges dieser
auseinandersetzung sind und dass das
auch so bleiben muss meine damen und
herren
neutralität im angesicht eines dritten
weltkrieges mit atomwaffen
ist eben nicht mit unterlassener
hilfeleistung eines privatmannes zu
vergleichen weil das opfer nicht
mitglied der freiwilligen feuerwehr ist
wie henrik bruder kürzlich in der welt
meinte
und nein liebe r wird zwar herausgeber
der welt wir versagen nicht vor der
geschichte als deutsche wenn wir auf
dieser neutralität
und auf dem frieden beharren
und meine damen und herren ich
weiß es viel kritik geübt worden wie wir
uns nach der rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten verhalten haben das will ich
nicht wieder aufrufen doch auch der
ukrainische präsident kann nicht wollen
die freiheit der ukraine auf den
trümmern europas zu errichten
im atomzeitalter ist der kompromiss kein
happy end
sondern
überlebensnotwendig das wusste gerade
egon bahr wärme zu lächeln
am ende wird eine neutrale und
demilitarisierte ukraine von allen
beteiligten das bekenntnis ab fordern ob
tod und zerstörung wirklich notwendig
waren dieses ergebnis zu erzielen und
die bundesregierung die mehr stolz daran
gemessen werden wie nachdrücklich sie
sich für eine solche lösung verwandt hat
es ist das eine nach dem völkerrecht ein
theoretisches recht auf bunten ist
bündniszugehörigkeit zu haben und das
andere in einer starken ordnung wie sie
nun einmal ist seinen platz mit klugheit
zu behaupten
einflusssphären verschwinden nicht
dadurch dass man sie leugnet und ein
abbruch aller beziehungen zu russland
ändert nichts an seiner lage größe und
seinem geopolitischen einfluss
pragmatisches handeln bleibt deshalb
auch hier oberstes gebot ich bedanke
mich
so wir blenden uns an dieser stelle aus
es war ein lebhafter schlagabtausch
heute vor allem über das 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr sind
noch heftige diskussionen zu erwarten
andrea maurer du hast die debatte vor
ort verfolgt den bundeskanzler wurde ja
in den letzten wochen oft vorgeworfen er
sage zu wenig war das heute die große
rede mit der er die gesellschaft
mitnimmt und auf das was noch kommen
kann vorbereitet
also zumindest ist es so dass von dem
großen aufschlag den der kanzler vor
drei wochen in seiner
regierungserklärung gemacht hat heute
wenig zu spüren war es hätte eine große
rede werden können es sind besondere
zeiten es ist das erste mal dass sich
die bundesregierung hier in der
generaldebatte sozusagen auf den
prüfstand stellt aber es hat die wucht
gefehlt der kanzler begann seine rede
damit dass er sich direkt an den
ukrainischen präsidenten gewandt hat und
damit indirekt wohl auch auf kritik
reagiert hat er hätte ihn letzte woche
im parlament sozusagen keine antwort
gegeben sei diese antwort schuldig olaf
scholz hat der ukraine die deutsche
hilfe zugesichert um dann in seiner rede
aber vor allem darauf einzugehen was
deutschland nicht tun wird also keine
flugsverbotszone keine nato
friedenstruppe kein öl und gas embargo
auch dem oppositionsführer friedrich
merz ist olaf scholz eine antwort in
seiner rede schuldig geblieben friedrich
merz hat vor olaf scholz gesprochen und
hat im grunde genommen angekündigt dass
der jubel der union zum sondervermögen
bundeswehr dass der vorbei ist dass die
union ist der ampel beim sondervermögen
bundeswehr sehr schwer machen wird in
der nächsten zeit und das ist sozusagen
erstmal von dem kanzler hier auch
unbeantwortet geblieben ja vielen dank
für diese einschätzung ich bedanke mich
auch bei ihnen für ihr interesse wer
möchte kann die debatte weiter auf
phoenix verfolgen ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen tag und sage tschüss bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]